Today on the show, oh, I don't give that away yet, right? We wait till the intro for that? Why would you, yeah, when have we ever done today on the show? Today is going to be, today is going to be. It's an all new with. Oh, that's okay. It's an all new with. Fuck it, let's do the show.
今天在节目中，哦，我还没打算剧透，对吧？我们留到开场白再说？你为什么，对啊，我们什么时候在节目一开始就剧透了？今天会是，今天会是。这是一个全新的...哦，没关系。这是一个全新的...管他的，我们开始吧。
It's SmartList. Let's go. Do you guys know what kind of a talent I am with whistling? I know a talent you don't have. Now, what's the deal with you and your whistling? This is something that you feel like you're good at. Yeah, I'm waiting for some sort of oral sex joke from you, Will, with blow or something like that.
这是《SmartLess》。我们开始吧。你们知道我在吹口哨方面有什么天赋吗？我知道你没有的天赋。话说你跟你的口哨是怎么回事？这是你觉得你很擅长的东西。对，我等着你开什么关于口淫的玩笑呢，威尔，用口交什么的。
No, probably. Jason, if you whistle, then you must sing, right? Can you sing? No, no, no. But I make up for my lack of singing with my incredible talent with my lips and my mouth. Will, teeing it up higher for you. No?
不，有可能。杰森，如果你会吹口哨，那你肯定会唱歌吧？你会唱歌吗？不，不，不。但我用我嘴唇和嘴巴的惊人天赋弥补了我不会唱歌的缺陷。威尔，这球我给你抛得够高了吧。不？
Don't want it? No, I just, low-hanging fruit. It's too low. It is. It's too low. It's too low. Too low even for me. I'll take it.
不想要？不，我只是，唾手可得。太低级了。确实。太低级了。太低级了。对我来说都太低级了。我接下了。
Go, Sean. Say it again. Set me up again. Forget it. We have too much of a respectable guest waiting in the wings. Would you guys like to get to the guest, or do you have something pithy to say on this Monday morning? I'm kind of grumpy this morning. Why? I don don't know why well guess guess what's going to cheer you up
来吧，肖恩。再说一遍。再给我抛个梗。算了。我们有个非常受人尊敬的嘉宾在后台等着呢。你们是想采访嘉宾，还是在这个周一早晨有什么妙语要说？我今天早上有点暴躁。为什么？我不知道为什么，好吧，猜猜什么能让你高兴起来
our next guest it's going to be exciting okay okay our next guest our our our only guest of this week sure the next guest in the long line of great guests here on smart lists gang who's hungry i'm hungry i hope starving. Yeah. Not only for the subject of food, but for charity and altruism. Because if there's a lineup in heaven, this man is going to skip it. Oh. This week's guest gives being human a good name. This man has not only been giving folks some of the best tasting, most inventive food for years. He's also been keeping millions of folks alive by making food available in some of the least fortunate among us. After earthquakes and hurricanes, he and his team are there
我们的下一位嘉宾，这将会很令人兴奋，好吧，好吧，我们的下一位嘉宾，我们唯一的...这周唯一的嘉宾，当然，是SmartLess这个大团队迎来的长长一串伟大嘉宾中的下一位。谁饿了？我饿了。我希望饿扁了。是的。不仅是为了食物这个主题，还为了慈善和利他主义。因为如果在天堂排队，这个人一定会插队。哦。本周的嘉宾为“人类”这个词树立了好名声。这个人不仅多年来一直为人们提供最美味、最具创意的食物，他还通过在一些最不幸的人群中提供食物，让数百万人生存下来。在地震和飓风过后，他和他的团队总是在那里
serving millions of meals for citizens and relief workers. Among the many places around the world, his organization, World Central Kitchen, has helped. There was Puerto Rico, Haiti, the Hurricane Harvey in Houston, the fires in California and Australia, the explosion in Beirut. This is all off the top of your head. And they're currently in India helping with COVID relief. He was named one of Time Magazine's most influential people twice. Will, you've only been named once. He's been awarded Humanitarian of the Year. It's also something you have not been awarded. I never was. By the James Beard Foundation.
为普通民众和救援人员提供数百万份热饭。在他的组织“世界中央厨房”帮助过的全球众多地方中，有波多黎各、海地、休斯顿的哈维飓风、加利福尼亚州和澳大利亚的山火、贝鲁特的大爆炸。这全都是你凭记忆随口说的。他们目前还在印度协助抗击疫情。他曾两次被《时代》杂志评为最具影响力人物之一。威尔，你只被评过一次。他曾被授予年度人道主义者称号。这也是你没有获得过的荣誉。我从来没有。由詹姆斯·比尔德基金会颁发。
And he has over 30 restaurants throughout the world receiving Michelin stars. And he's a New York Times bestselling author. So in other words, his parents are just- What the hell is he doing here? Really underwhelmed. Folks, please welcome the global treasure, Jose Andres.
他在世界各地拥有30多家获得米其林星级的餐厅。他还是《纽约时报》畅销书作家。所以换句话说，他的父母只是...他到底来这儿干什么？真的太让人幻灭了。各位，请欢迎全球宝藏，何塞·安德烈斯。
What? Wow. Yeah. Wow. All right. Look, there he is. It's such a pleasure to meet you. It is such an honor.
什么？哇。耶。哇。好吧。看，他来了。很高兴见到你。这真是个荣幸。
I think you're amazing. And everything that Jason said and everything that I know about you, it's an incredible accomplishment. Wow. It's really cool to meet you. Let's get right to it. What did you have for breakfast this morning? Yeah. Well, actually, in this last year, I went down 78 pounds.
我觉得你太棒了。杰森说的所有话，以及我对你的一切了解，这都是一个令人难以置信的成就。哇。很高兴能见到你。我们言归正传吧。你今天早上吃了什么早餐？对。好吧，其实在过去这一年里，我瘦了78磅。
78 pounds? Oh, my gosh. I'm so glad you didn't say kilos. I thought that you were going to rock us with the kilos. Yeah. Well, kilos is less confusing than pounds, let me tell you. But if you're going to lose weight, do it in pounds, people. You are going to feel so much more successful.
78磅？哦，天哪。我太高兴你没说公斤了。我还以为你要用公斤来吓我们呢。对。好吧，说公斤比说磅更不容易让人混淆，我跟你说。但如果你要减肥，就用磅来算，朋友们。你会觉得自己成功得多。
Yeah. Wow. I was 290. Now I'm 220, 220-something. Is that because you gained it and then lost it? Or you just lost Wow. I was 290. Now I'm 220, 220 something. Is that because you gained it and then lost it? Or you just lost it? I was overweight. I mean, listen to me.
耶。哇。我以前是290磅。现在是220磅，220多磅。是因为你先胖了然后又瘦了吗？还是你只是...哇。我以前是290磅。现在是220磅，220多磅。是因为你先胖了然后又瘦了吗？还是你只是瘦了？我以前超重。我是说，听我说。
When you are a chef and all your life, what you do is you love eating. You love creating. You love testing because I have to test my restaurants, the cocktails. I cannot say no to my chefs and my teams that are working so hard. No, you got to drink. You got to eat. Don't be rude. Only on the testing.
当你是一个厨师，你一生的工作就是热爱美食。你喜欢创作。你喜欢测试，因为我必须测试我的餐厅、鸡尾酒。我不能对那些工作极其努力的厨师和团队说不。不，你必须喝。你必须吃。别太粗鲁。只有在测试的时候。
Only on the, I eat more than I have to. And this without breakfast, lunch, or dinner. Now, can we assume that. This is why I've always thought, but Jason, I just want to say on that subject. I've always had this theory that most sommeliers are just alcoholics and they found a job in which they can dress it up. Right. You know what I mean? But sommeliers do a good work as hard as it is and they spit.
只有在...我吃的比我需要的要多。而且这还不算早晚餐。现在，我们可以假设...这就是我一直以来的想法，但是杰森，我只想就这个话题说几句。我一直有这样一个理论，大多数侍酒师其实就是酒鬼，他们只是找了一份能把酒瘾包装起来的工作。对吧。你知道我的意思吗？但侍酒师做得很出色，尽管工作很辛苦，他们会把酒吐出来。
It's easier to spit wine than it is to spit octopus with basil, right? I mean, you are there. What do you do? Where do you throw it? In front of whom? I mean, you are there. What do you do? Where do you throw it? In front of whom? I mean, it's, oh my God. Now, can we assume then that you have stopped tasting the food
吐酒总比吐带罗勒叶的章鱼容易吧？我是说，你在那儿。你怎么办？你吐在哪里？在谁面前？我是说，这，哦天哪。那么，我们是不是可以假设，你已经不再品尝你餐厅里的食物
and the wine at your restaurants and therefore we can't be sure of the quality anymore now that you've been losing weight? Controversial. Well, listen, he's saving his life. Hold on. And you are the guy that invited me? Thank God.
和葡萄酒了，因此既然你一直在减肥，我们就无法再确保食物的品质了？这很有争议。好吧，听着，他这是在救自己的命。等一下。你就是那个邀请我的人？谢天谢地。
I know, I know. You're like, what's going on with you, man? It's like... Who's taking care of quality control? He's a nice agent undercover. Who's handling your quality control if you're not spending as much time tasting your food around the world? Well, this is not about I, the person, man.
我知道，我知道。你会想，老兄，你这是怎么了？这就像...谁在负责质量控制？他是个卧底特工。如果你不花那么多时间在世界各地品尝食物，谁来负责你的质量控制？好吧，这不是“我”这个个人的问题，老兄。
This is about we, the people. I am only as good as the people I have around me. I have a team. I, the person, man. This is about we, the people. Yeah, Jason. I am only as good as the people I have around me. I have a team. Oh, you take smaller tastes. Jose, I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Smaller tastes.
这是关于“我们”，关于人民的问题。我能有多优秀取决于我身边的人。我有一个团队。我，这个个人，老兄。这是关于我们，人民的。对，杰森。我能有多优秀取决于我身边的人。我有一个团队。哦，你只是尝一小口。何塞，非常抱歉。非常抱歉。尝一小口。
Apologies. It's very aggressive this morning. Smaller tastes. Yes. And I've been doing fasting. I've done two 21-day fasting. Wow. Which actually you feel very good.
抱歉。今天早上火气很大。尝一小口。是的。我一直在断食。我已经做过两次21天的断食了。哇。其实你会感觉非常好。
Actually, you are not hungry. Actually, your body begins eating the fat that you have everywhere. And actually, you feel better than ever. When you say fasting, you mean no food at all? Just liquids? Liquids, less than 300 calories a day. Wow. But this works. I'm telling you, it works. Well, tell me about the first couple of days of that. Are you still decent to live with? Is it angry time? I get very angry when I'm telling you works. Well, tell me about the first couple of days of that. Are you still decent to live with? Is it angry time? I get very angry when I'm not eating. No, I'm cranky.
其实你并不饿。其实你的身体开始消耗你各处储存的脂肪。而且实际上，你感觉前所未有地好。你说的断食是指完全不吃东西吗？只喝液体？液体，每天不到300卡路里。哇。但这确实管用。我告诉你，这真的管用。好吧，跟我讲讲头几天的情况吧。你还能正常跟人相处吗？那是愤怒时刻吗？我一...我告诉你这管用。好吧，跟我讲讲头几天的情况吧。你还能正常跟人相处吗？那是愤怒时刻吗？我没东西吃的时候会非常生气。不，我很暴躁。
I'm grumpy anyway. Yeah, me too. Will's crumpy today. But what happens is two days after your body just takes over, begins doing what it's supposed to do. Yeah. Remember that humans, the Homo sapiens thing is something like, it's not a very well-given name, okay?
我本来就很暴躁。对，我也是。威尔今天脾气很坏。但情况是这样的，两天后你的身体就会接管一切，开始做它该做的事。对。记住，人类，智人这个称呼有点，这不是一个很准确的名字，好吧？
Yeah. We are more astrolupitecus. We are more ancient than that. I've been saying that for years. So our body, when we eat, makes fat to protect us from when we don't have food. Unfortunately, we have two types of people in the world. The ones that we have more food than we know what to do with it, and the ones that don't have even enough
对。我们更像南方古猿。我们比那更古老。我多年来一直这么说。所以我们的身体在进食时会产生脂肪，以防我们以后没有食物。不幸的是，世界上有两种人。一种是我们拥有的食物多得不知该怎么处理，而另一种则是甚至没有足够的食物
to feed themselves. Right. So unfortunately, people like me, which I have more food than I can do with it, my body is not very smart and transform everything I eat into what? Into fat. Why the body doesn't make the calories into smoke?
来养活自己。对。所以不幸的是，像我这样拥有过多食物的人，我的身体并不是很聪明，它把我吃的一切都转化成了什么？转化成了脂肪。为什么身体不把卡路里变成烟呢？
No, has to transform it into fat. No, that's not very smart. Right, right. No, it's too bad it didn't make it into cash. That would be great if your body just made all that extra stuff. That would be great. And you become like an ATM. So, Jose, let me ask you a question.
不，它必须把它们转化成脂肪。不，这不太聪明。对，对。可惜它没有变成现金。如果你身体里多余的东西都能变成现金就好了。那太棒了。然后你就成了一台取款机。所以，何塞，让我问你一个问题。
So, speaking of which, of the people who have not enough food to eat and people who have too much food to eat, you know, it seems to me, and this is just, you know, anecdotal at best, every time I see in the last few years that there's something going on, whether it's the hurricanes in Puerto Rico or wherever it is, I see you there on the ground providing meals for people. That's amazing. And it's such an incredible service that you are providing. And you're setting, not only are you helping to feed people, but you're setting an example for all of us of what we can do. And it seems to me the only thing you're really doing, you're just doing it. And when did that impetus happen for
说到这个，那些没有足够食物吃的人和食物太多吃不完的人，你知道，在我看来——这充其量也只是个轶事——每当在过去几年里看到哪里发生灾难，不管是波多黎各的飓风还是其他什么地方，我都会看到你在实地为人们提供食物。这太惊人了。你提供的服务太不可思议了。而且你正在树立榜样，你不仅在帮助人们填饱肚子，还在为我们所有人树立榜样，让我们看到我们能做些什么。在我看来，你真正做的唯一一件事，就是你一直在践行它。当时是什么促使你
you? What was that moment that you said, this is where I have to get on the ground and start doing it? Yeah, well, obviously it was many, many, many, many stories through my lifetime that began building, right? Like all of us, we are who we are thanks to those people that influence us. My mom, my dad, they were nurses. I saw empathy in those hospitals, the times I went with them to visit nurses, people working in hospitals. They were good people. My father and mother planted that seed in me. I was in the Spanish Navy. I think it's the first time I saw inequality beyond what I ever saw when I grew up in Barcelona. I only read it in books, but when I went to Africa, Latin America, I began seeing big inequality.
开始这样做的？那个时刻是什么时候，让你觉得这就是我必须亲临现场并开始行动的时候？对，好吧，很显然在我的一生中有许许多多、许许多多的故事一直在积累，对吧？就像我们所有人一样，我们之所以成为今天的我们，都要感谢那些影响过我们的人。我妈妈，我爸爸，他们都是护士。我在那些医院里看到了同理心，那是我跟随他们去探望护士、在医院工作的人们的那些时刻。他们都是好人。我父亲和母亲在我心中播下了那颗种子。我在西班牙海军服役。我想那是我第一次看到超越我在巴塞罗那长大的见识的、更大的不平等。我以前只在书本里读到过，但当我去了非洲、拉丁美洲，我开始看到巨大的不平等。
All those things began happening, right? Then I arrived in Washington, D.C. in 1993. I joined an organization called DC Central Kitchen, founded by a man called Robert Egger, who told me philanthropy seems is about the redemption of the giver, when philanthropy should be about the liberation of the receiver. Just work with me. I opened my restaurant on 7th and E. 1996, they discovered the home and office of Clara Barton, the woman that created the missing soldiers office, who took care of all the wounded soldiers during the Civil War. Like my mom, she was a nurse. Amazing what she did. Okay, what happened? One day, Katrina, I was in the comfort of my home watching
所有这些事情开始发生，对吧？然后我在1993年来到了华盛顿特区。我加入了一个名为“华盛顿特区中央厨房”的组织，由一个叫罗伯特·埃格尔的人创立，他告诉我，慈善事业似乎是关于施予者的救赎，而慈善事业本应是关于接受者的解放。只要跟我合作就好。我在第七街和E街开了一家餐厅。1996年，他们发现了克拉拉·巴顿的故居和办公室，她就是那个创立失踪士兵办公室、在内战期间照顾所有受伤士兵的女性。就像我妈妈一样，她是一名护士。她做的事太了不起了。好吧，后来发生了什么？有一天，卡特里娜飓风爆发了，我舒适地坐在家里看着
how men and women at the Superdome, which actually everybody had it wrong. Everybody thinks it's a sports venue. No, wrong, people. Arenas, stadiums are gigantic restaurants that entertain with NBA players or football players. It's true. How we left those men and women hungry. So that moment of inaction, with everything I learned before,
超级穹顶体育馆里的男男女女，其实所有人都搞错了。每个人都以为那是个体育场。不，大错特错，朋友们。竞技场、体育场其实就是巨大的餐厅，用NBA球星或橄榄球运动员来提供娱乐。确实如此。我们怎么能让那些男男女女挨饿呢。所以那个无所作为的时刻，加上我之前学到的一切，
planted the seed on me. I'm saying we have to do better. There's no way we're going to leave anybody hungry. I was in Cayman Islands with my friend Anthony Bourdain and Eric Rippert. When the earthquake hit Haiti, hundreds of thousands of people died in Port-au-Prince. A few days, a few weeks later,
在我心中播下了种子。我说我们必须做得更好。我们绝不能让任何人挨饿。我和我的朋友安东尼·波登以及埃里克·里佩尔在开曼群岛。当海地发生地震时，太子港有数十万人丧生。几天后，几周后，
I got on a plane and I landed in Dominican Republic. I drove to Haiti. I didn't go there to help. I went there to learn how chefs like me that feed the few, how can we part of feeding the many? That's very much the beginning of what became World Central Kitchen. In this pandemic alone, more than 60 million meals.
我登上一架飞机，在多米尼加共和国降落。我开车去了海地。我不是去那里帮忙的。我是去学习像我这样喂饱少数人的厨师，如何能成为喂饱多数人的一部分？这非常接近“世界中央厨房”的起点。仅在这次疫情期间，就提供了超过6000万份餐食。
Now we respond to fires, hurricanes, earthquakes, you name it. So Hurricane Katrina was kind of the thing for you, the thing that you saw and you were like, I've got to do something. Because it was for me too. I remember sitting on the couch watching that happen. I got off my butt. I flew down there.
现在我们应对火灾、飓风、地震，你能想到的都有。所以卡特里娜飓风对你来说算是一个转折点，让你看到并觉得：我必须做点什么。因为对我来说也是这样。我记得自己坐在沙发上看着那一幕发生。我从沙发上站起来。我飞到了那里。
I helped clean. I helped do everything, anything I could with actually a friend of ours, Meredith Walker. We flew down there together. Wow. I remember together. Wow. I remember that. Yeah, and so that was the first thing that inspired you to do that.
我帮忙清理。我帮忙做所有事，任何我能做的事，实际上是和一个我们的朋友梅雷迪思·沃克一起。我们一起飞到那里的。哇。我记得我们在一起。哇。我记得那个。是的，所以那是激发你这样做的第一件事。
But in my inaction, in my not being there, on me saying how this happened, and there was many chefs and many other people that randomly put a barbecue outside and began cooking. But responses like these, they need to be much more broader. They need to be very well organized. Long story short, we cannot leave people behind after one of the most dramatic events in their lives. And sometimes I feel like the system is not in place to respond fast and quick. World Central Kitchen, now we are fast and quick. Yeah, it's incredible.
但在我的无所作为中，在我不在现场的遗憾中，在我反思这一切是怎么发生的过程中，有很多厨师和许多其他人自发地在室外架起烧烤架开始做饭。但这样的应对措施需要更加广泛。它们需要组织得非常好。长话短说，在经历了一生中最戏剧性的事件之一后，我们不能把人们抛在脑后。有时我觉得这个体制没有到位来进行快速敏捷的反应。现在的“世界中央厨房”，我们行动迅速而敏捷。对，这太不可思议了。
I do have a question though, backing up. You moved in 93 to DC is what you said, I think. What was the first meal you had in America and what was it like? Okay, so I moved Washington DC in 93. But first time I came to America was in 1990 when I was in the Spanish Navy in a beautiful ship, a tall ship, the training ship for the Spanish midshipmen. Beautiful.
不过我有个问题，倒回前面。你刚才说你是93年搬到华盛顿特区的，对吧？你在美国吃的第一顿饭是什么？感觉怎么样？好吧，我是在93年搬到华盛顿特区的。但我第一次来美国是在1990年，当时我正在西班牙海军服役，在一艘漂亮的船上，一艘高桅横帆船，是西班牙海军见习军官的训练舰。非常漂亮。
Juan Sebastian del Cano. Unbelievable. First American port we touched was Pensacola in beautiful Florida, the city of the five flags, as they call it. And the first, first dish I ate was a soft-shell crab in this French restaurant that the owner came and invited me and took me there. And this first time ever I had any dish in America was that soft-shell crab. Wow. But when you were in the Navy, were you already a chef? Yeah.
胡安·塞巴斯蒂安·德尔卡诺号。难以置信。我们停靠的第一个美国港口是美丽的佛罗里达州彭萨科拉，也就是他们所说的五旗之城。我吃的第一道菜是软壳蟹，在这家法国餐厅里，老板走过来邀请我并把我带到了那里。我在美国吃的生平第一道菜就是那只软壳蟹。哇。但你在海军的时候，已经是厨师了吗？对。
You were cooking for the captain, right? Actually, I became the chef of the Admiral of Spain. And what happens with me is I was very young when I was in the seaport of Barcelona with my dad and I saw that tall ship and I told my dad, daddy, what do I have to do to go in that tall ship? And he told me, well, you have to be in the Spanish military. You have to be in the Navy. And if you are chosen, you'll go to that boat. Great. Life, many years later, I am in the Navy. And they decided, because I already was promising John Cook that I was going to cook for the Admiral. You had to see me when the Admiral is like,
你在为船长做饭，对吧？实际上，我成了西班牙海军上将的厨师。情况是这样的，我当年在巴塞罗那海港和我爸爸在一起时还很年轻，我看到了那艘高桅横帆船，我跟我爸说，爸爸，我得做什么才能上那艘高桅横帆船？他告诉我，嗯，你必须加入西班牙军队。你必须加入海军。如果你被选中了，你就能上那艘船。太棒了。多年后的生活里，我在海军了。他们决定——因为我已经是一个很有前途的年轻厨师——让我去给海军上将做饭。你应该看看当海军上将说...
welcome to our home. We're so happy you are here. And I tell him, well, you may be happy, but I'm not happy. I wanted to go on a boat. I'm tired of cooking. I want to see the world. So they told me, don't tell this to the admiral. Well, first opportunity I got is the first thing I told him. Good news. The admiral told me, listen, let's do
欢迎来到我们的家。我们很高兴你来到这里。我告诉他，好吧，你可能很高兴，但我可不高兴。我想上一艘船。我厌倦了做饭。我想看世界。所以他们告诉我，千万别跟上将这么说。好吧，我得到的第一机会，这就是我跟他说地第一句话。好消息。上将告诉我，听着，我们做个交易吧。
a deal. This boat you want to go on doesn't leave port until six months from today. Why are you going to stay here with me and my family? You know, feed us, cook for us. And the day before that ship goes away, I send you. You know, it happens. He kept his word, I kept mine. And for me, it was the adventure of my life. And how long were you on that ship? That was six months. It was great because it's the first time I left Europe, very much.
你想要上的那艘船从今天起六个月内都不会离港。你为什么不留在这里陪我和我的家人呢？你知道的，养活我们，给我们做饭。在那艘船起航的前一天，我派你走。你知道吗，事情就是这样。他遵守了诺言，我也遵守了我的。对我来说，那是人生中的一次冒险。你在那艘船上呆了多久？那是六个月。太棒了，因为那是我就此第一次真正离开欧洲。
And I went to places like Ivory Coast and Abidjan and Rio de Janeiro and Brazil and Fortaleza and Dominican Republic. Mar-a-Lago. Mar-a-Lago. I don't remember visiting Mar-a-Lago back in time. Not many do. Yeah. Yeah. flying in there with the wings of an angel,
我去了象牙海岸、阿比让、里约热内卢、巴西、福塔莱萨和多米尼加共和国。海湖庄园。海湖庄园。我不记得过去曾参观过海湖庄园。没几个人去过。对。耶。乘着天使的翅膀飞进那里，
as Will loves it when I say. I imagine it's difficult and complicated to coordinate your efforts along with some of the other federal responses too, like say FEMA or something like that. Is that a smooth thing? Is that a complicated thing? Is it a contentious thing? I imagine that they appreciate you helping them,
正如威尔喜欢我这么说的那样。我猜，协调你们的努力以及一些联邦应急反应（比如联邦紧急事务管理局FEMA什么的）一定既困难又复杂。这是一件顺利的事吗？这是一件复杂的事吗？这是一件充满争议的事吗？我猜他们很感激你帮助他们，
but also at times maybe their ego might not want you guys to get in there first or have a bigger impact. How does all that work? No, I think the men and women of FEMA, of the National Guard, they are great people. They are people that they give their best. Red Cross and, yeah. They are, essentially, they are all good people. You always have the one or two, but people are good.
但有时也许他们的自尊心可能不想让你们率先介入或者产生更大的影响。这一切是如何运作的呢？不，我认为FEMA和国民警卫队的男男女女们，他们都是伟大的人。他们是付出最大努力的人。红十字会还有，是的。他们，本质上，都是好人。你总会遇到一两个奇葩，但人们都是善良的。
People have good intentions. The truth is that very big organizations are very slow. And as bigger as they get, the slower they become. And the challenge I was facing was if you are an organization that claims itself have on their name emergency as one of the words. Emergency, when it's about food and water, it's very simple to understand. The urgency of now is yesterday. You cannot be planning for what you're going to feed them next month. You have to feed them today. And so... Will does that. He hoards food for like a week
人们都有好的意图。事实是，非常大的组织都非常缓慢。而且规模越大，它们就变得越迟钝。我面临的挑战是，如果你是一个声称自己的名字中带有“应急”这个词的组织。应急，当它涉及到食物和水时，是非常容易理解的。当下之急就是昨天。你不能为下个月要给他们喂什么做计划。你今天就得喂饱他们。所以...威尔就是这么做的。他囤积了大约一周的食物
because he just planned, right? I like to eat. It's rare that I'm actually not eating on the podcast right now. That is very rare. It is very rare. I mean, look, these are all great things. And obviously you go in and you do this stuff,
因为他提前做好了计划，对吧？我喜欢吃。我一边录播客一边在吃东西，这其实挺罕见的。这非常罕见。这非常罕见。我是说，看，这些都是很棒的事情。显然你介入并做了这些事情，
but it's kind of almost part of Jason's question, really. Not only do you have to deal with all the bureaucracy of these huge agencies that are filled with lots of people who are doing amazing things, but there are regulations and they want you to do it this way or that way. On top of which, you have to organize, you know, you have to get all this food down there and prepare it and the logistics of food and keeping it fresh and all that kind of stuff into areas that are in distress. That must be very tough.
但这几乎算是杰森问题的一部分了。你不仅要应付这些庞大机构的所有官僚作风，里面充满了做着了不起事情的大量人员，而且还有各种规章制度，他们希望你按这样或那样的方式去做。最重要的是，你必须组织，你知道，你必须把所有这些食物运到灾区并准备好，还要处理食物的物流、保持新鲜以及所有这些杂七杂八的事情，运往那些处于困境的地区。那一定非常艰难。
Okay. I would love to tell you that it's super complicated and super difficult, but let me give you very quick examples. In this pandemic alone, right, we put 3,000 restaurants working at once, almost 350,000 meals a day, which is not a huge number. I mean, World Food Program, the men and women, they do millions of meals a day all around the world. So I'm not saying this for show off. It's the contrary. But our 350,000 meals are very specific when hospitals all of a sudden don't have anybody that feeds them. At the beginning of the pandemic, you tell me where, Harlem, Oakland, San Antonio, Newark, you name it, we've been there. We are there. We create the systems, Yabit Center. We create the
好吧。我很想告诉你这超级复杂、超级困难，但让我给你举几个非常简单的例子。仅在这次疫情期间，对吧，我们同时让3000家餐厅投入运营，每天提供将近35万份餐食，这不是一个庞大的数字。我是说，世界粮食计划署的男男女女们，他们在世界各地每天提供数百万份餐食。所以我这样说不是为了炫耀。恰恰相反。但我们的35万份餐食是非常具体的，当医院突然没有人给他们提供食物时。在疫情刚开始时，你告诉我哪里，哈姆雷特、奥克兰、圣安东尼奥、纽瓦克，随便哪个地方，我们都去过。我们在那里。我们建立了系统，雅各布·贾维茨中心。我们在雅各布·贾维茨中心门外建立了
system to provide meals right outside the Yabit Center. Central Park, we did when they opened that field hospital. We were there before even the hospital was open. India right now, 17 cities, 65 hospitals, thousands of meals a day. We began not today when, or last week when we read it on the news, we began like six, seven weeks ago. Bahamas, you remember two years ago, a hurricane, one of the biggest hurricanes in the history of the Caribbean, next to Maria, Dorian, Category 5. 80,000 people lost their homes, very much everybody in the two islands north of the Bahamas, Abaco and Grand Bahama. Within five days, within four days, we were providing almost 80,000 meals a day with six helicopters, two seaplanes. So, you know. But you see that.
提供餐食的系统。中央公园，当他们开放那个野战医院时，我们也做了。甚至在医院开放之前我们就已经在那里了。印度现在，17个城市，65家医院，每天数千份餐食。我们不是今天才开始，也不是上周在新闻上读到时才开始，我们在大约六、七周前就开始了。巴哈马，你还记得两年前的一场飓风吗，加勒比海历史上最大的飓风之一，仅次于玛丽亚，多利安，5级飓风。8万人失去了家园，几乎是巴哈马北部两个岛屿上的所有人，阿巴科和大巴哈马。在五天内，在四天内，我们用6架直升机、2架水上飞机，每天提供将近8万份餐食。所以，你知道的。但你看到了。
So, this is my point. So, you see this hurricane's coming. Everybody knew it was going to hit the Bahamas. In anticipation of that, do you guys mobilize and say, okay, here's our plan. We know that the Bahamas, we know that there are going to be people who are hungry. Let's go. Let's be ready. We're in Florida. We've got the helicopter. That's a great question. Obviously, we know that there are going to be people who are hungry. Let's go. Let's be ready. We're in Florida.
所以，这就是我的观点。所以，你看到这场飓风正在逼近。每个人都知道它会袭击巴哈马。在预见到这一点的情况下，你们会动员起来说，好吧，这是我们的计划。我们知道巴哈马会有很多人挨饿。我们走吧。准备好吧。我们在佛罗里达。我们有直升机。这是一个很好的问题。显然，我们知道会有很多人挨饿。我们走吧。准备好吧。我们在佛罗里达。
We've got the helicopter. That's a great question. Obviously, we've been learning. In the old days, we will be more responsive. Even our response, like in Maria, Puerto Rico, we were able to be very quickly in our response. In Bahamas, the team of World Central Kitchen was already in place. We were in Nassau, and we were in Fort Lauderdale. Why? Because you want to be inside and you want to be in the outside.
我们有直升机。这是一个很好的问题。显然，我们一直在学习。过去，我们会反应得更快。甚至我们的反应，比如在玛丽亚飓风期间的波多黎各，我们也能够做出非常迅速的反应。在巴哈马，“世界中央厨房”的团队已经就位了。我们在拿骚，我们在劳德代尔堡。为什么？因为你想身处内部，你也想身处外部。
So it depends how bad it is inside. You can't be giving support from the outside. So, yes, we are there. Yes, we have a plan, but careful, we don't overplan. I always say that we learn in 2020 that organizations, families, individuals like you, we have a tendency to plan too much. When you plan too much, what happens, my friends? That things usually never go as you planned them. And if you don't train your teams to embrace complexity and to be good on adaptation, they fail miserably.
所以这取决于内部情况有多糟。你无法完全从外部提供支持。所以，是的，我们在那里。是的，我们有一个计划，但要注意，我们不会过度计划。我总是说，我们在2020年了解到，组织、家庭、像你们这样的个人，我们都有过度计划的倾向。当你们计划得太多时，我的朋友们，会发生什么？事情通常永远不会像你计划的那样发展。如果你不训练你的团队去拥抱复杂性并擅长适应，他们就会惨败。
adaptation, they fell miserably. So our motto is plan less, adapt more, be more about software, not so much about hardware, meaning many organizations for whatever is the response is about the equipment you bring from A to Z. What's happening with us? I believe that across the planet is hundreds, millions of people in the food business, millions of farmers, millions of cooks, million of restaurant owners, million of food distributors, that when we bring them all together, we can respond to anything. One more example in the middle of the pandemic, Beirut, the big explosion in Lebanon, World Central Kitchen, with people of Lebanon. In 12 hours, we were delivering close to 20,000 meals a day with the help of 10 restaurants around ground zero. I was able to land myself three days later or four days later. By the time I landed, the entire system of feeding first responders,
适应，他们就会惨败。所以我们的座右铭是少计划，多适应，更多地依靠软件，而不是硬件，这意味着许多组织无论面对什么反应，都专注于从A到B带来的设备。而我们是怎么做的呢？我相信地球上有成百上千、数以百万计从事食品行业的人，数百万农民，数百万厨师，数百万餐厅老板，数百万食品分销商，当我们把他们所有人聚集在一起时，我们能够应对任何事情。再举一个例子，在疫情期间，贝鲁特，黎巴嫩发生大爆炸，“世界中央厨房”与黎巴嫩人民在一起。在12小时内，在零地带周围10家餐厅的帮助下，我们每天运送将近2万份餐食。我在三天或四天后得以亲自降落。等我降落时，为急救人员、
firefighters, hospitals, volunteers was already in place. But Jose, this type of effort, even if a world organization like, let's say, NATO or what, if they were to mount this, it would take an infrastructure that would be, that you would need multiple countries to run. It would take funding that multiple countries would need to chip in to hit the threshold required. So how can you, an incredibly accomplished, you know, philanthropist and chef and restaurant owner, how can you grab all of these assets, all of this money, all of this infrastructure? I imagine it takes a great deal of donations.
消防员、医院、志愿者提供食物的整个系统已经建立好了。但是何塞，这种类型的努力，即使是一个世界组织，比方说北约什么的，如果他们要发起这种行动，将需要一个基础设施，你需要多个国家来运营。这将需要多个国家共同出资才能达到所需的门槛。所以你，一个成就卓著的慈善家、厨师和餐厅老板，怎么能把所有这些资产、所有这些资金、所有这些基础设施都抓在手里？我猜这需要大量的捐款。
Can people donate to the organization? And is that the only way that it stays afloat? Or are you subsidized by governments as well? Now, recently, we've been talking about some countries that they love to work with us. Indonesia, they've done. We've been there in tsunamis and earthquakes. I was myself in Providencia, in this beautiful island in the Caribbean, owned by Colombia, which was hit by a very big back-to-back hurricanes last year, Iota and Eta. We did a great response there. So, there's
人们可以向该组织捐款吗？这是维持运营的唯一途径吗？还是你们也得到了政府的补贴？现在，最近我们一直在谈论一些他们喜欢与我们合作的国家。印度尼西亚，他们做过。我们在海啸和地震时去过那里。我本人曾去过普罗维登西亚，加勒比海这个美丽的岛屿，属于哥伦比亚，去年遭到接连两次非常大的飓风袭击，也就是“伊奥塔”和“埃塔”。我们在那里做出了出色的反应。所以，有
many governments and even agencies here that they began talking to us. But for us, it's very important to understand that so far we've been really funded by people in America and around the world, $1 at a time, $10 at a time, some people with bigger donations. And how can people do that real quick? WorldCentralKitchen.org. There you can learn the work we do. Wck.org. wck.org, gotcha. wallcentralkitchen.org. Both work. Gotcha. Smartless is brought to you in part by Airbnb.
许多政府甚至这里的机构都开始跟我们对话。但对我们来说，非常重要的一点是我们要明白，到目前为止，我们的资金确实是由美国和世界各地的人们通过一美元一美元、十美元十美元这样捐助的，有些人则有更大的捐款。人们怎么能快速做到这一点？WorldCentralKitchen.org。在那里你可以了解我们所做的工作。Wck.org。wck.org，明白了。wallcentralkitchen.org。两个都行。明白了。Smartless部分赞助商为Airbnb。
Okay. We all know Sean. We love him. He's a great guy. Sean Hayes from the TV and the films and the Smart List podcast. But guess what? Sean Hayes, he's got a big family reunion coming up, and he has booked an Airbnb for his family.
好的。我们都认识肖恩。我们都很喜欢他。他是个极好的人。肖恩·海斯，来自电视、电影以及《SmartLess》播客。但你猜怎么着？肖恩·海斯，他有一个盛大的家庭团聚即将到来，他为他的家人预订了一套Airbnb民宿。
Sick idea. That's so good. How can you figure out a way to get everybody together in one place? The best way to do it is to get an Airbnb. Maybe you've stayed in an Airbnb before and thought to yourself, this actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could be an Airbnb. It could be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away.
太棒的主意了。太棒了。你怎么能想出一个办法把大家聚在一个地方呢？最好的办法就是订一套Airbnb。也许你以前住过Airbnb，心里想过：这其实听起来挺可行的。也许我的房子也可以成为一个Airbnb。这可以很简单，从一个空房间开始，或者当你不在家时出租你的整套房子。
You could be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it. Maybe you're planning a ski getaway this winter. While you're away, you could Airbnb your home and make some extra money toward the trip. Whether you could use extra money to cover some bills or for something a little more fun, your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. What if each time you made a purchase, you got a little something back? With Rakuten, you can. You can earn cash back on just about anything you buy from over 750 stores. If you've ever bought electronics, home decor, fashion, and beauty, or booked a trip, well, you could have gotten cash back.
你可能正坐拥一套Airbnb却浑然不知。也许你正计划今年冬天去滑雪度假。当你外出时，你可以把你的房子挂在Airbnb上，为这次旅行赚点外快。无论你是想用外快来支付一些账单，还是为了做点更有趣的事情，你的房子可能比你想象的更值钱。请访问 airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。如果你每次购物都能拿回一点返利，那会怎么样？通过Rakuten，你可以做到这一点。你可以在从750多家商店购买的几乎任何东西上赚取现金返还。如果你曾经买过电子产品、家居装饰、时尚美妆产品，或者预订过旅行，嗯，你本可以拿到现金返还的。
But don't worry, it's not too late. It's free and easy to use, and you get cash back deposited in your PayPal account or sent to you as a check. Earn cash back at stores like Sephora, Old Navy, and Expedia. It's the smartest way to shop, plain and simple. Start your shopping at Rakuten.ca or get the Rakuten app. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. Or get the Rakuten app. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. Hello, I am Alice Levine and I am one of the hosts of Wondery's podcast, British Scandal.
但别担心，现在还不晚。它免费且易于使用，你获得的现金返还直接存入你的PayPal账户或以支票形式寄给你。在Sephora、Old Navy和Expedia等商店赚取现金返还。这是最聪明的购物方式，简单明了。在Rakuten.ca开始你的购物，或者下载Rakuten应用程序。即 R-A-K-U-T-E-N。或者下载Rakuten应用程序。即 R-A-K-U-T-E-N。你好，我是爱丽丝·莱文，我是Wondery播客节目《英国丑闻》的主持人之一。
On our latest series, The Race to Ruin, we tell the story of a British man who took part in the first ever round-the-world sailing race. Good on him, I hear you say. But there is a problem, as there always is in this show. The man in question hadn't actually sailed before. Oh, and his boat wasn't seaworthy. Oh, and also tiny little detail, almost didn't mention it. He bet his family home on making it to the finish line. What ensued was one of the most complex cheating plots in British sporting history. To find out the full story, follow British Scandal wherever you listen to podcasts or listen early and ad-free on Wondery Plus on Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. And now back to the show. How are you able to do this
在我们最新的系列节目《毁灭竞赛》中，我们讲述了一个英国人参加史上第一次环球航行比赛的故事。做得好，我听到你这么说。但正如这个节目的一贯风格，这里有个问题。这位主角其实以前根本没航海过。哦，他的船也不适航。哦，还有个微小的细节，差点没提。他把自家的房子压上，就为了抵达终点线。随之而来的是英国体育史上最复杂的作弊阴谋之一。想要了解完整的故事，请在任何你听播客的地方订阅《英国丑闻》，或者在Apple Podcasts或Wondery App上的Wondery Plus提前收听无广告版。现在回到节目中。你是如何做到这一点的，
and keep your restaurant empire, I say, up and going? mean i was thinking the same thing i mean do you sleep at all i mean i i do um listen i told you it's not me who makes it happen right it's not it's not jose there's some oversight that you are lending at a minute you said i do when he said you sleep you said i do but I get the sense you don't get a lot of sleep. Is that true? Yeah, you know, I can take 30 minutes nap here, 20 minutes nap there. What about a funny gummy? Yeah, a little bit of a gummy will get you,
并且同时让你的餐饮帝国蒸蒸日上的？我是说我刚才也在想这件事，我是说你睡觉吗？我是说我...听我说，我告诉你这不是我一个人办到的，对吧？不是，不是何塞...有一些监管工作你在花时间...当他说“我做到了”的时候，当他说“你睡觉吗”时，你说“我做到了”，但我感觉你睡眠并不多。是真的吗？对，你知道的，我可以在这儿打个30分钟的盹，在那儿打个20分钟的盹。那来一颗搞笑软糖怎么样？对，一点点软糖会让你...
but then I'll get you hungry, and then you'll blow your fast. Never mind. A gummy? What is that? Jason, do you have something you want to tell the group? No, no, no. Gummy bear?
但随后你会觉得饿，然后你的断食就泡汤了。算了。软糖？那是什么？杰森，你有什么想对大家坦白的吗？不，不，不。小熊软糖？
What? Yeah, they're medical marijuana gummies. Ah, a gummy. That's a gummy? Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to say one thing. Like, if you go to buy, like I did, chocolate that has gummy marijuana,
什么？对，那是医用大麻软糖。啊，软糖。那是软糖？对。对。我要说一件事。比如，如果你像我一样去买含有大麻成分的巧克力，
read the instructions of the tablet of chocolate. Don't need the tablet of chocolate like you want to eat the entire tablet of chocolate like I did. And if it says only eat one square, don't eat the other 24 squares. That's correct. Because if he's telling you eat one square every eight hours and you eat 24 squares in the same hour, that chocolate is really having a gummy effect on you. Did things get weird for you, Jose? Well, my English improved 10 times. That's the good thing.
请阅读巧克力板上的说明。不要像我一样，像想吃完整块巧克力那样把整块巧克力板都吃掉。如果它上面写着只吃一格，就别把剩下的24格全吃了。没错。因为如果它告诉你每八小时吃一格，而你在同一个小时内吃了24格，那块巧克力真的会在你身上产生软糖（大麻）的效果。你当时觉得很诡异吗，何塞？嗯，我的英语提高了十倍。这是好事。
My accent, I mean, all of a sudden, it's like Ron Howard was like, finally, I'm going to give you a movie actor opportunity because now I can understand what the fuck you say, Jose. So gummies are good for accents. It's like your tongue gets loose. For some reason, my tongue and English doesn't get comfortable. You sound beautiful to me. Keeping it on the subject of food and hunger is something that baffles you, I'm sure.
我的口音，我是说，突然之间，就好像朗·霍华德觉得：终于，我要给你一个演电影演员的机会了，因为现在我能听懂你他妈在说些什么了，何塞。所以软糖对改善口音很有用。就像你的舌头变松了。不知为什么，我的舌头和英语就是不太习惯。但在我听来你声音很美。继续回到食物和饥饿这个话题，这肯定让你感到困惑。
It baffles me a bit too. Is there anything that we can do that would be a better management of food waste, like in restaurants? management of food waste, like in restaurants, how we might be able to help, you know, the unhoused or anyone else in society that might be suffering from hunger? How can we take some of this, the food that's being wasted and use it better? Listen, people don't want our pity. People want our respect. It's plenty of food that we produce in America. It's plenty of food that we produce on planet Earth. Actually, big problems, they have very simple solutions. At heart, what's going on is that many of the issues we face, we have a whole bunch of people overcomplicating things
这也让我有点困惑。我们有没有什么办法能更好地管理食物浪费，比如在餐厅里？管理食物浪费，比如在餐厅里，我们如何才能帮助无家可归的人或社会中任何其他可能忍受饥饿的人？我们如何才能把这些被浪费的食物利用得更好？听着，人们不需要我们的同情。人们需要我们的尊重。我们在美国生产了大量的食物。我们在地球上生产了大量的食物。其实，大问题往往有非常简单的解决方案。核心在于，我们面对的许多问题，都有一大群人在把事情过度复杂化，
to, I think, keep claiming we need them. Sometimes if somebody is not able to accomplish something, success into a problem, those people, they should just be removed forever. If we have the same people running certain issues, let's say United Nations, how many years we've been saying we're going to be ending childhood hunger? Science, I remember 40, 50 years. My friends, childhood hunger is something we can all commit to end, bring in all the countries, all the rich countries. But where there is a will, there is a way.
我猜是为了继续宣称我们需要他们。有时如果某人无法解决某个问题并取得成功，这些人就应该永远被免职。如果我们继续让同一拨人来处理某些问题，比方说联合国，我们已经说要消除儿童饥饿多少年了？科学，我记得有40、50年了。我的朋友们，儿童饥饿是我们所有人都可以承诺去消除的事情，只要让所有国家，所有富裕国家都参与进来。但有志者事竟成。
I don't sense it's really a will more than giving a big speech where everybody claps. And after the claps end, everybody goes their home and everybody forgets. We need to start making everybody, especially the big leaders and the big organizations, more responsible for their claims and their promises. And if they don't deliver, major things have to happen. Yeah, I agree. Jose, have you ever hosted a cooking show or something? You'd be amazing. Yeah.
我感觉这并不是真正的意志，而更像是一场人人都鼓掌的大型演讲。掌声一停，每个人就各回各家，把这事忘得精光。我们需要开始让所有人，特别是大领袖和大组织，对他们的主张和承诺承担更多责任。如果他们没有兑现，重大事件就必须发生。对，我同意。何塞，你以前主持过烹饪节目吗？你会非常棒的。对。
I never pass the accent. Yeah, yeah. I don't listen to me. That's not true. No, let me tell you. In Spain, during three years, I had a primetime show at 7 p.m., 7.30 p.m. Yes, I heard that. In the major channel, meaning I had like 24% share of ratings in Spain alone.
我的口音一直过关。对，对。别听我的。那不是真的。不，让我告诉你。在西班牙，我有三年时间在晚上7点、7点半黄金时段主持节目。是的，我听说过。在主流频道，这意味着单在西班牙我就有大约24%的收视份额。
Wow. In America, I had one on PBS that was great because I wanted to show Spain and, you know, when they don't, I got on PBS, which is a great channel. I love it. Great tote bags. What I really want to know is, and Sean asked you what you had for breakfast this morning,
哇。在美国，我在公共电视网（PBS）主持过一个节目，非常棒，因为我想展示西班牙，你知道，当他们不看时，我上了PBS，这是一个很棒的频道。我很喜欢。有很多精美的环保袋。我真正想知道的是——肖恩问过你今天早上吃了什么早餐——
what's your guilty pleasure food that you're like, this is not high oat cuisine, this is whatever, but I love it, like Doritos or whatever. Is there something that you like that you're ashamed, this is not high haute cuisine, this is whatever, but I love it, like Doritos or whatever. Is there something that you like that you're ashamed of, food-wise? Just food-wise. Don't start crying, though, Jose. Do not start crying.
你有什么罪恶快感的食物，就是那种你会觉得“这不是高级料理，这只是随便什么，但我就是爱吃”，比如多力多滋或者别的什么。有没有什么食物是你喜欢但又觉得有点不好意思的？单纯从食物角度来说。不过先别哭啊，何塞。千万别哭。
No, no, I mean, I like everything. I mean, I like ketchup on white rice. Ketchup on white rice? On white rice? Yeah. What are you, English? It's fine. Ketchup, as we used to call it. Ketchup. Ketchup.
不，不，我是说，我什么都喜欢。我是说，我喜欢白米饭加番茄酱。白米饭加番茄酱？加在白米饭上？对。你是什么人，英国人吗？这挺好的。番茄酱（Ketchup），我们以前管它叫Ketchup。番茄酱。番茄酱。
Ketchup on white rice. I've never heard of that. I'm going to try that. And with a fried egg is to die for. And if you add the sausage, this is the closest thing. We have arroz a la cubana. But now you're becoming a chef. Now you're becoming a cook.
白米饭加番茄酱。我从没听说过这个。我要去试试。再加个煎蛋，简直美味得不得了。要是再加点香肠，这就是最接近古巴风味饭的东西了。但你现在成大厨了。你现在成厨师了。
No, no. Okay, okay. But you know I like caviar. Me, my guilty pleasure is caviar. Those little black balls. And yeah, do you like it with the eggs, with the onions, with the,. Me, my guilty pleasure is caviar. Those little black balls. And yeah, do you like it with the eggs, with the onions, with the, how do you dress up?
不，不。行，行。但你知道我喜欢鱼子酱。我呀，我最大的罪恶快乐就是鱼子酱。那些小黑球。对啊，你喜欢配鸡蛋吃，配洋葱吃，配……我呀，我最大的罪恶快乐就是鱼子酱。那些小黑球。对啊，你喜欢配鸡蛋吃，配洋葱吃，配……你怎么搭配着吃？
No, nothing. Straight up, finger. With the finger? So no little pancake? No, no, no. No, no, little pancakes. He's in the Caspian Sea. He's reaching under the water.
不，什么都不配。直接吃，用手指。用手指？所以不配小薄饼？不，不，不。不，不配小薄饼。他在里海呢。他把手伸到水底下去了。
Let me tell you, let me tell you, my friend, when they give you things like blinis and little pancakes and onions, it's because they don't have enough caviar to feed everybody. That's it. Period. Let me ask you something about ketchup, because I love ketchup. I grew up putting ketchup in a lot of stuff because my mom burnt a lot of the food.
我跟你说，我跟你说，我的朋友，当他们给你端上布利尼小圆饼、小煎饼和洋葱这些东西时，那是因为他们没有足够的鱼子酱来分给大家。就是这样。没别的。我问你个关于番茄酱的事，因为我很喜欢番茄酱。我从小就在很多东西里加番茄酱，因为我妈妈把很多菜都烧焦了。
But she was great, too. But isn't it true that a lot of American ketchup doesn't have tomatoes in it? Huh. Well, hold on a second. Number one. Here we go once again, and we're mired in controversy over here on Swap. Yeah, you're trying to get me in trouble with Hank.
但她也很棒。不过，很多美国番茄酱里面其实没有番茄，难道这不是真的吗？哈。好吧，等一下。第一。我们又来了，我们在 Swap 节目这里又陷入了争议。对啊，你想让我和汉克惹上麻烦。
Listen to me. I mean. Listen to me. I believe in longer tables, no higher walls. I didn't say product name. I know, I know, but let me tell you. Number one, when you mention ketchup, you need to remember that the first early ketchups in America themselves, they were not even based out of tomatoes.
听我说。我是说。听我说。我崇尚加长的餐桌，而不是更高的墙。我没说产品名字。我知道，我知道，但我要告诉你。第一，当你提到番茄酱时，你需要记住，美国最早期的番茄酱本身甚至都不是用番茄做基底的。
No kidding. They were made out of mushrooms. They were made out of oysters. They were made out of blackberries. Those were the early ketchups. What are you talking about? This is insane. Tomato took over for different reasons.
不是吧。它们是用蘑菇做的。它们是用生蚝做的。它们是用黑莓做的。那是早期的番茄酱。你在说什么呢？这太疯狂了。番茄因为各种原因最终取而代之。
Why? Tomato took over in a huge way, which I think is a loss to America because it's good to have diversity. It's the tomato cartel. It's good to have diversity. Tomato cartel. We need diversity, people. Diversity. More types of ketchup in your life will make you better. Different color ketchup. You know, they've made it. It's called mustard.
为什么？番茄以一种巨大优势占据了主导地位，我认为这对美国来说是个损失，因为保持多样性是件好事。这就是番茄卡特尔。保持多样性是件好事。番茄卡特尔。我们需要多样性，各位。多样性。生活中多几种番茄酱会让你的生活更美好。不同颜色的番茄酱。你知道，他们已经做出来了。这东西叫芥末。
No, that's not ketchup. That's mustard. It's something else. But it's a different color man he's talking about diversifying the color of ketchup but ketchup came really an influence from asia mixed with other things but ketchup should be more diverse cannot only be tomato yeah and cannot only be one brand needs to be more what about mayonnaise where do you fall on mayonnaise? Because I mean, boy, I love mayonnaise. I fall right on top of it. I know you do. I like mayo too.
不，那不是番茄酱。那是芥末。那是别的东西。但它是另一种颜色，伙计，他在谈论让番茄酱的颜色多样化，但番茄酱确实受到了亚洲风味的影响，并与其他东西混合在一起，不过番茄酱应该更多元化，不能只有番茄味，是的，也不能只有某个单一品牌，需要更多……蛋黄酱呢？你对蛋黄酱持什么态度？因为我是说，天哪，我太喜欢蛋黄酱了。我完全沉迷于它。我知道你喜欢。我也喜欢蛋黄酱。
I am a mayo boy. I mean, I'm a mayo boy. With fries? I think it's disgusting. No, no. What are you talking about is disgusting?
我是个蛋黄酱男孩。我是说，我就是个蛋黄酱男孩。配薯条？我觉得这太恶心了。不，不。你在胡说八道什么，怎么就恶心了？
It's olive oil, man. I'm from Spain. We're the kings of olive oil. Why are you saying it's disgusting? Wait, wait, what is mayonnaise? Actually,
那是橄榄油，伙计。我来自西班牙。我们是橄榄油之王。你凭什么说它恶心？等等，等等，蛋黄酱到底是什么？其实，
hold on a second. Hold on a second. Grab mayonnaise between your fingers. Mentally think second. Grab mayonnaise between your fingers. Mentally think it. Grab mayonnaise with your fingers. And start rotating your fingers with the beautiful mayo. It's a sensation, man.
等一下。等一下。用你的手指抓一点蛋黄酱。脑海里想一下。等一下。用你的手指抓一点蛋黄酱。脑海里想象一下。用你的手指抓一把蛋黄酱。然后开始用你那漂亮的蛋黄酱搓动手指。这是一种感觉，伙计。
It's all coming. And bring it to your lips and put it to your tongue. And all of a sudden you have that amazing, shiny, silky texture inside your mouth. And the mayo is telling you, baby, what you've been all my life. Mayo in your mouth. Mayo will change your life if you give mayo an opportunity, man. Let mayo be part of your life. Let your mouth be dripping with mayo. Jose, you know, the reason that Jason often, he doesn't like mayo because he's often in reviews of his acting, they describe him as mayonnaise.
那种感觉全来了。把它送到嘴唇边，贴到舌头上。突然之间，你嘴里就有了那种惊人的、闪亮的、丝滑的质感。蛋黄酱在对你说，宝贝，你就是我这一生一直在寻找的。把蛋黄酱含在嘴里。如果你给蛋黄酱一个机会，蛋黄酱会改变你的生活，伙计。让蛋黄酱成为你生活的一部分。让你的嘴里滴满蛋黄酱。何塞，你知道杰森不怎么喜欢蛋黄酱的原因吗，因为在他的表演评论中，人们经常把他形容为蛋黄酱。
So he's got a, yeah, I know, I know. Yeah, it's true. But mayonnaise with fries, come on, mayo with fries is not. Listen, Canada, quiet, okay? We don't have any mayonnaise on French fries. Who cooks for you, Jose? Well, I love any mayonnaise on French fries. Who cooks for you, Jose? Well, a lot of people cook for me. My wife cooks for me.
所以他有种，对，我知道，我知道。对，是真的。但薯条配蛋黄酱，拜托，薯条配蛋黄酱不是。听着，加拿大，安静点，好吗？我们在法式薯条上可不加什么蛋黄酱。谁给你做饭，何塞？好吧，我可喜欢在法式薯条上加蛋黄酱了。谁给你做饭，何塞？好吧，很多人给我做饭。我老婆给我做饭。
I cook for her. I cook a lot at home. You asked me what I had today for breakfast. Yeah, yeah. I had just a coffee. By the way, what we call American coffee, but the American coffee I make is simply the best American brew coffee
我给她做饭。我在家里经常做饭。你问我今天早上吃了什么。对，对。我只喝了一杯咖啡。顺便说一句，我们管这叫美式咖啡，但我做出来的美式咖啡绝对是人类历史上最棒的美式滴滤咖啡。
in the history of mankind. What's the name? Wow. No, that's a mother, because I use different coffees from different parts. But this is the way I make is simply the best American brew coffee in the history of mankind. What's the name? Wow. No, that's a mother, because I use different coffees from different parts. But this is the way I make it. It's 25 grams of coffee, 375 grams of the water. I pour the water slowly in a dripping, slowly.
叫什么名字？哇。不，这简直是个神作，因为我用了来自不同产地的不同咖啡豆。但我这样煮出来的美式滴滤咖啡绝对是人类历史上最棒的美式咖啡。叫什么名字？哇。不，这简直是个神作，因为我用了来自不同产地的不同咖啡豆。但我做它的方法是：25克咖啡粉，375克水。我把水慢慢倒进去，一滴一滴地慢慢往下滤。
You can hear the noise of the water hitting the coffee grounds and the coffee is like happy. The aroma is coming out. And then when it's filtered, I grab the little pitcher with the coffee. I get this amazing glass. And I come up like 10, 20, 30 centimeters up in the air. The stream of black coffee drops into the cup. And all that foam begins coming up.
你能听到水滴拍打咖啡粉的声音，咖啡好像很高兴。香气散发出来了。然后过滤好后，我拿起装咖啡的小壶。我拿来一个精美的玻璃杯。然后我把手抬高，大概离杯口10、20、30厘米的高空。黑咖啡细流落入杯中。所有的泡沫开始涌现。
Foam, foam, foam, air. And then when you bring that coffee to your lips with those bubbles, shiny that you can see through like there are thousands of eyes looking at you, that coffee will change your mind in ways that in the morning you will feel like re-empowered. I agree. Sean has that same experience when he's in the takeout line at Sonic, when he's there at the— You know what I do?
泡沫，泡沫，泡沫，空气。然后，当你把带着那些晶莹气泡的咖啡送到唇边，你可以透过气泡看到成千上万双眼睛在看着你，那种咖啡会以某种方式改变你的心态，让你在清晨感到重新充满了力量。我同意。肖恩在刺猬索尼克（Sonic）的外卖排队队伍里也有过同样的经历，当他在那个——你知道我平时是怎么做的吗？
I do French press every morning, Avi. And so I don't do it on the pot like you do on the stove, which is old school, but I just do—I pour the hot water on the grounds, just enough to cover the grounds to let the bubbles burst, so it lets a little bit of that sort of the bitterness out. The flowering. It's called the flowering. The flowering. I pour the the flowering. The flowering.
阿维，我每天早上都用法国压滤壶。所以我不用像你那样用炉子上的那种老式咖啡壶，我只是——我把热水倒在咖啡粉上，刚好没过咖啡粉，让气泡破裂，这样就能把一部分那种苦味释放出来。这叫闷蒸（flowering）。这叫闷蒸。闷蒸。我把剩下的水倒进去，让它静置一会儿。然后我用绝不是沸腾的水轻轻搅拌一下，因为我不想烧焦那些咖啡粉。然后，等它浸泡了一段时间后，我慢慢地把滤压杆压下去。这是一个完整的流程。我们这是在做美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）的节目吗？好吧，欢迎你们，各位。
I pour the rest of the water in, let it sit. Then I stir it a little bit with never boiling water because I don't want to burn those grounds. And then I slowly, after it's steeped for a while, I push down. And it's a whole process. We're on NPR or something. Well, welcome, guys.
欢迎来到文化的世界，各位。但你们觉得怎么样，我喝咖啡的时候，我喜欢这样。我喜欢它。我醒来时咖啡已经做好了，我把它倒进杯子里然后喝掉。对待食物也是一样，对待食物也是一样，这就是为什么我、我不做饭的原因，我不理解为什么要花半小时去做一道只能吃五分钟的饭。何塞，你听到那个了吗？半小时？
Welcome to culture, you guys. But what do you think about when I have my coffee, I like it. I like it. It's already made when I wake up up i pour it in the cup and i drink it the same thing with same thing with food i that's the reason i don't i don't cook is that i don't i don't understand the concept of taking a half an hour to cook something that's gonna give me five minutes to eat jose did you hear that half an hour? Jason, it's not half an hour. It takes you organization, man. Three minutes.
杰森，那可不是半小时。这需要你有条理，伙计。三分钟。
Listen. I've got to chop stuff. Jason, was this French guy, and I don't mention French guys in public conversations often. Yeah, better not. I'm from Spain. This is great.
听着。我得切东西。杰森，有个法国家伙，我可不常在公开谈话中提到法国家伙。对，最好别提。我来自西班牙。这太棒了。
So he said, tell me what you eat, and I will tell you who you are. Jason, how you eat and what you eat is a part of you, my man. It's so sad. Now, this is all I eat, and I want you to give me— Jason, be honest. Be fucking honest with Jose right now.
所以他说，告诉我你吃什么，我就会告诉你你是什么人。杰森，你怎么吃以及你吃什么，这都是你的一部分，老兄。这太可悲了。现在，这就是我全部的饮食，我要你给我——杰森，说实话。在何塞面前说句他妈的实话吧。
I'm going to be—I would never lie to Jose. I want him—okay. Let me tell you what I eat every single day, and I want you to give me one thing in each dish that I can add to it to spice up my life a little bit. Number one, for breakfast every morning, I have oatmeal with almonds and raisins, and I put a little bit of amigoyam cinnamon on top.
我要——我绝不会对何塞撒谎。我希望他——好吧。让我告诉你我每天吃什么，我希望你在我的每道菜里加一样东西，好给我的生活增添一点情调。第一，我每天早晨吃燕肉片（oatmeal），配上杏仁和葡萄干，上面再撒一点点肉桂粉。
And then for lunch and dinner, I have like a 40-pound salad with chicken chopped up in it. Full stop. That's just I'm in a rut, and I can't get out of it. Psycho. Like a psychopath. But these things are quick to make, and I'm done, and I'm moving on with the rest of my life. I'm just, I'm putting some food in the tank. Because you eat because it's a necessity,
然后午餐和晚餐，我吃大约40磅重的沙拉，里面切碎了鸡肉。句号。这就是——我陷入了刻板的生活套路，而且无法自拔。精神病。就像个精神病患者。但这些东西做起来快，我弄完就吃，然后继续我生活中的其他事情。我只是，我只是往油箱里加点油。因为你吃东西是因为它是必需品，
not because it's out of enjoyment. Correct. In the bare amount. Correct. Okay, Jason, I'm so sad to hear that this is it. I mean, number one, why you chop the chicken? What the chicken has done to you? Don't chop the chicken.
而不是因为它是为了享受。没错。仅仅维持生存的最低分量。没错。好吧，杰森，听到这些我真替你难过。我是说，第一，你为什么要切鸡肉？鸡肉对你做错了什么？别切鸡肉。
I mean, chicken has done nothing to us, people. Chicken are good people, right? They may have feathers, but that's fine. Let the chicken be the chicken. Okay, but I'm not going to get there. Number one, on the appetizer and the thing you have, this weird thing with that oatmeal.
我是说，鸡肉对我们什么都没做，各位。鸡是好人，对吧？它们可能长了羽毛，但那没关系。让鸡做一只真正的鸡吧。好吧，但我不会接受这个。首先，在你的开胃菜和你吃的那种东西里，你对燕麦片有种奇怪的执念。
And I mean, my wife has something like that too. And we are discussing our marital arrangements. But I will add dragon fruit. Dragon fruit in my oatmeal. Yeah, in your oatmeal. What the hell is dragon fruit? Because dragon fruit is going to bring freshness. It's going to bring the nice crunchy seeds.
我是说，我老婆也有类似的东西。我们正在讨论我们的婚姻安排。但我会加入火龙果。火龙果加进我的燕麦片里。对，加进你的燕麦片里。火龙果到底是什么鬼？因为火龙果会带来清爽感。它会带来好吃的脆脆的籽。
It's going to be a slightly sweetness, natural. Texture. Texture is a big part of it. Oh my God, it's so good. And on the salad, I will say put Spanish olive oil. Spanish olive oil. Spanish sherry vinegar. Okay.
它会带来淡淡的自然甜味。口感。口感是其中很大部分。噢天哪，太棒了。至于沙拉，我会说放点西班牙橄榄油。西班牙橄榄油。西班牙雪莉醋。好吧。
And I will add some sesame seeds. And don't chop the chicken, man. There you go. Use a fork and a knife like every human being. Why you chop it like chop? No, but he uses the fork like it's just in service of shoveling it into his mouth. Now, let me ask you something. Jason, do you ever speak to your ingredients?
我还会加点芝麻。而且别切鸡肉，伙计。就这样。像每个正常人一样用刀叉。你为什么把它切得粉碎？不，但他用叉子的样子，就像只是为了把它铲进嘴里一样。现在，我问你个问题。杰森，你跟你的食材说过话吗？
I mean, you speak to the chicken before you eat it. Do you establish a relationship before? Sometimes it's the only person who'll listen. Yeah, exactly, because the family's usually eaten already. I chew a lot. I'm a very slow eater. Is that a good thing or a bad thing? It's got to be a good thing, right?
我是说，你在吃鸡肉之前会跟它说话吗？你在吃之前会建立一段关系吗？有时候它是唯一会听我说话的人。对，完全正确，因为家里人通常已经吃过了。我咀嚼很多。我是一个吃东西非常慢的人。这是件好事还是坏事？这肯定是个好事，对吧？
Yeah, chewing is good. I chew a lot. Yeah, chewing. So usually there's no one else around the table, so I will talk to the salad. The cows chew a lot, too. The cows are chewing all day. I mean, you know?
对，咀嚼是好事。我咀嚼很多。对，咀嚼。所以通常桌子周围没有别人，所以我就会跟沙拉说话。奶牛也咀嚼很多。奶牛一整天都在咀嚼。我是说，你知道吗？
You feel like a cow. Then they throw it up and they re-eat it. Is that right? Wait, wait, wait. Sean, tell Jose what you eat. Because Jason obviously eats that. It's a very sort of California, and we've become a very bland society here
你感觉自己像头奶牛。然后它们把东西吐出来再重新吃一遍。是这样吗？等等，等等，等等。肖恩，告诉何塞你吃什么。因为杰森显然吃那种东西。这非常加利福尼亚风格，我们这里已经变成了一个非常乏味的社会，
where he has the thing, and then he just has the salad with the chicken, and that's all he can have, and blah, blah, blah. It's a very sort of California. We've become a very bland society here. He has the thing, and then he just has the salad with the chicken. That's all he can have and blah, blah, blah. It's very controlled, and it's so lame. So we're done with Jason. Sean, tell them what you eat. I eat a lot of tuna fish sandwiches. I eat a lot of hamburgers. I eat a lot of pizza.
他吃那种东西，然后只吃加了鸡肉的沙拉，这就是他能吃的一切，巴拉巴拉。这非常加利福尼亚风格。我们这里已经变成了一个非常乏味的社会。他吃那种东西，然后只吃加了鸡肉的沙拉。这就是他能吃的一切，巴拉巴拉。这被控制得太死板了，太逊了。所以我们不管杰森了。肖恩，告诉他们你吃什么。我吃很多金枪鱼三明治。我吃很多汉堡。我吃很多披萨。
But you're in California, no? Yeah. Did you have Monterey prawns? They're in season right now. No,. Do you have Monterey prawns? They're in season right now. No, what's that? Monterey prawns. Do they have that at Hardee's? Because if they have it at Hardee's, he's had it.
但你在加利福尼亚，对吧？对。你吃过蒙特雷对虾吗？现在正是它们的季节。没有，……你吃过蒙特雷对虾吗？现在正是它们的季节。没有，那是什么？蒙特雷对虾。哈代汉堡（Hardee's）有卖这个吗？因为如果哈代汉堡有的话，他肯定吃过。
No, you have to go and find them. Do you eat sea urchin? I mean, you should put sea urchin in your tuna melt. Oh, God, sea urchin. I don't want anything with tentacles or suction cups. Sea urchin don't have tentacles. What are you talking? It has the spines.
不，你得亲自去找。你吃海胆吗？我是说，你应该把海胆放进你的金枪鱼融化三明治（tuna melt）里。哦，天哪，海胆。我可不要任何带触手或吸盘的东西。海胆没有触手。你在说什么？它有刺。
It's like a purple spine. I don't want the spines. No, I don't want the spines. Sea urchin. I'm cooking. You know where I'm cooking right now? I'm cooking an octopus and snails. Suction cups. Right now? It's cooking right now at your house? Yeah, yeah. Wow. I'm making a paella with rabbit and snails, and I'm serving an appetizer of octopus, Galician style. Very good. What do you think about the French really love to cook lapin. What do you think about the French? Lapin is bread. I mean, French are good people. They live north of Spain. Yeah, I'm goading you.
就像紫色的刺。我可不要那些刺。不，我不要那些刺。海胆。我在做饭。你知道我现在在哪里做饭吗？我在做章鱼和蜗牛。吸盘。现在吗？现在正在你家里做吗？对，对。哇。我在做一道兔肉蜗牛西班牙海鲜饭（paella），我还要端上一道加利福尼亚风格（Galician style）的章鱼作为开胃菜。非常不错。你觉得法国人真的很喜欢做兔肉（lapin）这事怎么样？你觉得法国人怎么样？Lapin 是面包。我是说，法国人是好人。他们住在西班牙北部。对，我是在激怒你。
They live north of Spain. Are you happy that the Pyrenees are there to separate you? Yeah, I'm not going to lie to you. We learn a lot from us, but where do they go for the good ingredients? They come to Spain. Where do they go for the beach?
他们住在西班牙北部。庇里牛斯山脉把你们隔开，你觉得高兴吗？对，我不会对你撒谎的。我们从彼此身上学到很多，但他们去哪里找优质食材？他们来西班牙。他们去哪里找海滩？
They come to Spain. Where do they go for wine that actually, I mean, let's face it, people. When you go to a French restaurant. Let it out. The maitre d' didn't even tell you bienvenue. And already $20. Yeah, right. Only because he talks to you in French.
他们来西班牙。他们去哪里找那些实际上——好吧，让我们面对现实吧，各位。当你走进一家法国餐厅。说出来吧。领班甚至都不会跟你说一句“欢迎光临”（bienvenue）。就已经20美元了。对吧。仅仅因为他跟你说法语。
It's $20. I know. I have a lot of French friends. I mean, they sit you down. You're going to have less now. The sommelier tells you something in French. $10 more before you chose the wine. I mean, come on, people.
就得20美元。我知道。我有很多法国朋友。我是说，他们让你坐下。你现在的钱变少了。侍酒师用法语跟你说点什么。在你选酒之前又多收10美元。我是说，拜托，各位。
I mean, really. I like French people, but oof. Jose, have you ever gone out on a hunting trip and killed an animal and then cooked that animal? Because like you just said, you got a paella going with rabbits. I started thinking like, where does he get these rabbits from?
我是说，真的。我喜欢法国人，但——呃。何塞，你有没有去过狩猎之旅，亲手打死一只动物然后把它烹饪了？因为就像你刚才说的，你正在做兔肉西班牙海鲜饭。我开始想，他从哪弄来的这些兔子？
Have you ever gone out and like on purpose hunted for a meal that you and some other chefs might get together and cook? Yeah, I know this is going to get me in trouble. No. We can always cut it. Hunting in the right way is good. We'll cut it.
你有没有特意去为了做一顿饭而打猎，然后你和其他厨师聚在一起烹饪？对，我知道这会给我惹麻烦。不。我们总是可以把它剪掉。以正确的方式狩猎是件好事。我们会剪掉的。
Keeps everything. So I've done, no, no, don't cut it. Just leave it. Okay. But quail and partridge and fessing and then cook it. Oh, yeah. Many times. Well, it makes sense.
保持一切。所以我做过，不，不，别剪掉。就留着吧。好吧。但是鹌鹑、鹧鸪、野鸡，然后烹饪它们。哦，是的。很多次。好吧，这说得通。
I mean, every animal we've ever eaten has been killed for us to eat. And so why not have the chef himself kill that animal and then cook that animal as opposed to it being killed on some farm, right? Well, there you go. I mean, that's- It makes sense. Correct. And you only eat what you hunt, which I think is the-
我是说，我们吃过的每一只动物都是为了让我们吃而被杀死的。所以为什么不让厨师本人杀死那个动物，然后烹饪那个动物，而不是让它在某个农场被杀死呢？好吧，就是这样。我是说，那是——这说得通。没错。而且你只吃你捕获的东西，我认为这——
Yeah. Let me tell you, my friend, I like meat. I have a meat concept called bazaar meat, but more and more we're gonna see that we're gonna eat less quantity of that meat, of higher quality of the meat we eat. I like that. And I think vegetables are going to win the day.
对。我告诉你，我的朋友，我喜欢肉。我有一个关于肉类的概念叫“集市肉类（bazaar meat）”，但我们会越来越多地看到，我们将吃更少数量的肉，但我们吃的肉质量会更高。我喜欢这个。而且我认为蔬菜最终会获胜。
I think nothing is sexier than a pineapple, my friend. I mean, think about it for a second. You put a steak in your mouth, okay? First 10 seconds, the flavors, I'm a man here, a strong person. 10 seconds later, what you have is a piece of shit in your mouth,
我认为没有什么比菠萝更性感的了，我的朋友。我是说，仔细想想。你把一块牛排塞进嘴里，好吧？前10秒，各种风味，我在这里是个大男人，一个坚强的人。10秒后，你嘴里剩下的就是一堆狗屎，
tasteless, that you have to keep munching for the next 30 seconds of your life. You cannot establish a conversation. Nobody understands my English because that piece of crap is in my tongue. Shit, you put a pineapple in your mouth. The pineapple is sexy, fresh, juicy. You keep, everything is good. So go with pineapple. It's better than a steak. You know, I saw this interesting documentary once where it said, you know, that people think that you got to eat a bunch of protein to stay big and strong. And then they bring up this good point that gorillas, elephants, giraffe,
毫无味道，你还得在接下来的30秒里不停地咀嚼。你根本无法展开对话。没人能听懂我的英语，因为那块破东西塞在我的舌头上。该死，你把一块菠萝放进嘴里。菠萝是性感的、新鲜的、多汁的。你一直在嚼，一切都很好。所以选菠萝吧。它比牛排好。你知道，我曾经看过一个有趣的纪录片，上面说，你知道，人们认为你必须吃一堆蛋白质才能保持高大强壮。然后他们提出了一个很好的观点，那就是大猩猩、大象、长颈鹿，
they're all vegetarians. They don't eat meat and they've got all that size. So you can live a big, robust life just eating vegetables and fruit your whole life. Is that correct? I would say, I mean, Blue Wells, I mean, I would say you're correct. But again, we need to be smarter the way we eat. There's so many good things out there. It's so many good, I mean, asparagus
它们全都是素食主义者。它们不吃肉，但它们长得那么大。所以你完全可以一辈子只吃蔬菜和水果，过着宏大而健壮的生活。这是真的吗？我会说，我是说，蓝鲸，我是说，我会说你是对的。但同样，我们需要更聪明地进食。外面有那么多好东西。有那么多好东西，我是说，芦笋，
when they're in season, strawberries when they're in season, the green peas when they're in season. I love them. The morels, the chanterelles. Smash peas on toast. Oh, my God, the bounty of. And do you know the most American fruit that no American knows? Sean Hayes.
当它们当季的时候，当季的草莓，当季的青豆。我太喜欢它们了。羊肚菌，鸡油菌。把青豆捣碎抹在吐司上。哦，天哪，大自然的慷慨。你知道美国人最不知道的最具美国特色的水果是什么吗？肖恩·海斯。
The most American fruit that no American knows. Pow-pows. Pow-pows. They're very big here in the east, from Virginia all the way to Ohio. Lewis and Clark, actually, they ate pow-pows in their way back. And pow-pow is this amazing—it tastes like in between a mango and a chirimoya. I don't know if you know what a chirimoya is, but if you don't, just Google it. And it's fascinating.
美国人最不知道的最具美国特色的水果。泡泡果（Paw-paws）。它们在东部非常普遍，从弗吉尼亚一直延伸到俄亥俄州。事实上，刘易斯和克拉克在回程的路上就吃过泡泡果。泡泡果是一种神奇的水果——它的味道介于芒果和番荔枝（chirimoya）之间。我不知道你知不知道什么是番荔枝，但如果你不知道，去谷歌一下就行了。这太吸引人了。
So the most amazing fruit in America, America is unaware of it. Have you ever had, let me ask you this, Jose, have you ever had what in Canada we call a Saskatoon, which is like a wild blueberry? It's got a little red flavor, a little red color to it. It's gross in the wild. Incredible. So when I was growing up.
所以美国最惊人的水果，美国人却对它一无所知。你有没有吃过——我问你这个，何塞，你有没有吃过我们在加拿大称之为萨斯卡通莓（Saskatoon）的东西，它就像一种野生蓝莓？它带有一点点红色的风味，带有一点点红色。在野外长得很难吃。太不可思议了。所以当我长大的时候。
Yeah, I think I ate them once. Yeah, brilliant. We used to have Saskatoon pie my grandmother would make and you'd go out, you'd pick the Saskatoons and make incredible. Incredible. Jason, what are you drinking? It looks yellow. It's water and orange-flavored electrolytes.
对，我想我吃过一次。太棒了。我们以前吃过我奶奶做的萨斯卡通莓派，你会出去，采摘萨斯卡通莓，然后做出不可思议的美味。不可思议。杰森，你在喝什么？看起来黄黄的。是水加橙味电解质。
Don't ask. Electrolytes? It's chemicals. Hold on. You have electrolytes to do a podcast? I do a lot of sweating. I do a lot of sweating during this podcast. Hold on.
别问。电解质？这是化学成分。等等。你做个播客还要喝电解质？我出了很多汗。在这个播客录制期间我出了很多汗。等等。
Oh, Jose, I love this. Keep going, keep going. Electrolytes? I do a lot of sweating. I do a lot of sweating during this podcast. Oh, Jose, I love this. Keep going. Keep going. Electrolytes. I'm prepping for my exercise afterwards, to be frank. Ah, okay. Jose really came alive. He really lit up when you told him that you were taking electrolytes for this. In-laws, love them or hate them, you're pretty much stuck with them. And when you're a ruler in the Middle Ages, that can be a serious problem. It might even land you dead. I'm Dan Jones, and on season four of This Is History, I'm telling the story of England's weirdest king, Henry III. He's in way over his head, and he's surrounded by bloodthirsty relatives with their eyes on his throne. Hi, I'm Anna.
哦，何塞，我太喜欢这个了。继续，继续。电解质？我出了很多汗。在这个播客录制期间我出了很多汗。哦，何塞，我太喜欢这个了。继续。继续。电解质。老实说，我是在为接下来的锻炼做准备。啊，好吧。何塞真的复活了。当你告诉他你为了这个在喝电解质时，他整个人都兴奋起来了。岳父母，无论你是爱他们还是恨他们，你基本上都得忍受他们。而当你身处中世纪成为一国之君时，这可能会是个严重的问题。它甚至可能让你送命。我是丹·琼斯（Dan Jones），在《这就是历史》（This Is History）第四季中，我将讲述英格兰最奇特的国王亨利三世的故事。他完全无法掌控局面，身边还环绕着对他的王位虎视眈眈、嗜血成性的亲戚们。嗨，我是安娜。
And I'm Emily. We're the hosts of Wanderie's podcast, Terribly Famous, a show where we bring you outrageous true stories about our most famous celebrities. And our latest season is all about the one and only Katie Price. You might think you know her, you might have an opinion, but there is way more to the former glamour model than just her cup size. Yes, this is a woman who's gone from pinup to publishing sensation. We all have teenage dreams. And for Katie, it was simple.
我是埃米莉。我们是温德里（Wondery）播客《声名狼藉》（Terribly Famous）的主持人，在这个节目中，我们为你带来关于我们最著名名人的离奇真实故事。我们的最新一季全关于独一无二的凯蒂·普赖斯（Katie Price）。你可能觉得你了解她，你可能对她有看法，但这位前魅力模特身上远不止她的胸围那么简单。是的，这个女人从一个海报女郎变成了出版界的轰动人物。我们都有少年的梦想。对凯蒂来说，很简单。
Massive fame and everlasting love. I just wanted to kiss a boy. Just one boy. Well, she does kiss a few boys, but there are plenty of bumps along the way. And when I say bumps, I mean terrible boyfriend choices, secret dates with spiky-haired pop stars, and a tabloid press that wants to tear her apart at every opportunity.
巨大的名气和永恒的爱情。我只是想和一个男孩接吻。就一个男孩。好吧，她确实和几个男孩接吻了，但这一路上磕磕绊绊。当我说是磕磕绊绊时，我是说糟糕的男朋友选择，与顶着刺猬头流行歌星的秘密约会，以及一个恨不得在每个机会都把她撕碎的小报记者群体。
And she surprises even herself when suddenly she becomes a role model for a whole new generation of young women who want to be just like her. Want to hear more? Follow Terribly Famous wherever you listen to podcasts or listen early and ad-free on Wondery Plus on Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. I'm Afua Hirsch. I'm Peter Frankopan. And in our podcast, Legacy,
而她甚至连自己都感到惊讶，因为她突然成为了一代渴望变得和她一样的年轻女性的偶像。想听更多吗？请在您收听播客的任何地方关注《声名狼藉》，或者在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或 Wondery App 上的 Wondery Plus 提前收听无广告版。我是阿富阿·希尔什（Afua Hirsch）。我是彼得·弗兰科潘（Peter Frankopan）。在我们的播客《传奇》（Legacy）中，
we explore the lives of some of the biggest characters in history. This season, we delve into the life of Mikhail Gorbachev. This season has everything. It's got political ideology. It's got nuclear Armageddon. It's got a love story. It's got betrayal. It's got nuclear Armageddon. It's got a love story. It's got betrayal. It's got economic collapse. One ingredient that you left out, legacy. Was he someone who helped make the world a better place, saved us all from all of those terrible things?
我们探讨历史上一些最重要人物的生活。这一季，我们深入探讨米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫（Mikhail Gorbachev）的一生。这一季应有尽有。这里有政治意识形态。这里有核末日。这里有一个爱情故事。这里有背叛。这里有核末日。这里有一个爱情故事。这里有背叛。这里有经济崩溃。你漏掉了一个要素，传奇。他是一个帮助世界变得更美好、将我们所有人从所有这些可怕事情中拯救出来的人吗？
Or was he a man who created the problems and the challenges of many parts of the world today? Those questions about how to think about Gorbachev, you know, was he unwitting character in history or was he one who helped forge and frame the world? And it's not necessarily just a question of our making. There is a real life binary in how his legacy is perceived. In the West, he's considered a hero. And in Russia, it's a bit of a different picture. So join us on Legacy for Mikhail Gorbachev.
还是说他是一个制造了当今世界许多地方的问题和挑战的人？那些关于如何看待戈尔巴乔夫的问题，你知道的，他到底是历史上的一个无意识角色，还是一个帮助塑造和构建世界的人？这不一定只是我们主观臆断的问题。对于他的历史遗产如何被看待，现实中确实存在着二元对立。在西方，他被认为是一个英雄。而在俄罗斯，情况则有点不同。所以，欢迎来到《Legacy》收听关于米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫的内容。
Jose, you get asked this all the time, but is there a meal that sticks out in your head that is your absolute favorite that you've had? It's because of the people you were with or the food, or is there just one meal in your whole life you're like, you'll never forget it? Oh my God, I had so many of those. Of course.
何塞，你经常被问到这个问题，但有没有哪一顿饭深深印在你的脑海里，是你吃过的绝对最爱？是因为和你在一起的人，还是因为食物本身，或者你整个人生中就是有那么一顿饭，让你觉得：你永远不会忘掉它？噢，天哪，我有过太多这样的经历了。当然。
I had plenty of those. But it's this guy, Ferran Adria. His restaurant is closed now. You'll never be able to eat there again. He's probably the best chef in the history of mankind, period. Most creative. What's his name again? What's his name again?
我有过很多次这样的经历。但这个人，费兰·阿德里亚（Ferran Adria）。他的餐厅现在关门了。你再也无法在那里吃东西了。他可能是人类历史上最伟大的厨师，句号。最有创造力的。他叫什么名字来着？他叫什么名字来着？
Ferran, F-E-R-R-A-N, Adria. A-D-R-I-A. Adria. He's my mentor. He's my master. He's my best friend. This guy has a mind that goes through this prism of ideas and light and sensations and feelings and smells. And he understands.
费兰，F-E-R-R-A-N，阿德里亚（Adria）。A-D-R-I-A。阿德里亚。他是我的导师。他是我的师父。他是我的最好朋友。这家伙的脑海里仿佛穿梭着各种思想、光芒、感觉、情感和气味的棱镜。他懂。
He's like a food whisperer, man. He understands food like nobody. And I'm meeting his restaurant. They usually will be anywhere between 30 and 45 dishes. Without electrolytes. I mean, electrolytes they charge you anyway. This will be... What about, did they have a chopped salad with chicken?
他就像个食物密语者，伙计。他比任何人都懂食物。我去他的餐厅用餐。他们通常会有30到45道菜。还不包含电解质。我是说，不管怎样电解质他们都要收费。这将会是……话说回来，他们有加鸡肉的切碎沙拉吗？
But then, one I remember three Christmas ago, the 24th of December, I am in Cadiz, in the south of Spain, where my wife is. We began cooking at 10 a.m. in the morning. We were cooking until 2 a.m. on the 25th. I made this very big fire with 20, 30 terracotta balls.
但后来，我记得三个圣诞节前，12月24日，我在加的斯（Cadiz），在西班牙南部，我妻子在那儿。我们早上10点开始做饭。我们一直做到25日凌晨2点。我用20、30个红陶球生了一个非常大的火。
We were grilling octopus and boiling shrimp that just came from the oceans and doing baby eels and gooseneck barnacles and figalas. And baby, oh my God, that meal, because it was family, because we were in the middle of nowhere, because we were cooking all day, probably was one of those happy, happy moments in my life that I want to recreate again.
我们在烤章鱼，煮刚刚从海洋里捞上来的虾，做小鳗鱼、鹅颈藤壶和无花果。宝贝，哦天哪，那顿饭，因为是一家人，因为我们在荒郊野岭，因为我们一整天都在做饭，那可能是我一生中最快乐、最快乐的时刻之一，我想再次重现它。
Sean, what's your greatest meal of all time? Probably spaghetti from a place called Maggiano's. Is that true? Yeah, any time of week. Huh. Where is that? It's at the Grove. It's at the Grove. Oh my God.
肖恩，你吃过最棒的一顿饭是什么？可能是某个叫马贾诺（Maggiano's）的地方做的意面。真的吗？对，一周的任何一天都可以。哈。那是哪里？在格罗夫购物中心（The Grove）。在格罗夫购物中心。哦，天哪。
It's at a shopping mall. Is there any part of yourself that says, just why bother? Yeah, why don't you just take yourself out around back? I have a question for Sean. So, Sean, how do you eat your spaghetti? You put the entire fork in, or you get one spaghetti from the beginning of the spaghetti? Tell me how you eat your spaghettis, and I will tell you what type of podcaster you are.
在一家购物中心里。你内心深处有没有哪个部分在想：到底折腾个啥呀？对啊，你为什么不直接找个后巷把自己了结了呢？我有个问题想问肖恩。那么，肖恩，你吃意面是怎么吃的？你是把整把叉子都插进去，还是从意面的第一根开始吃？告诉我你是怎么吃意面的，我就会知道你是什么类型的播客主持人。
Okay, so Will can probably answer that for me. He cuts it. No, he eats his spaghetti. It's very hot. First of all, it's very hot because it's just out of the microwave, so he has to peel the lid off the container because it comes in a container.
好吧，威尔大概能替我回答这个问题。他把它切断。不，他吃意面。非常烫。首先，它非常烫，因为它刚从微波炉里拿出来，所以他必须把容器上的盖子撕下来，因为它是用容器装着的。
And then he just pours it, and it's like a drink. I do. He eats it like a drink, like a beverage. I shove it in my mouth. Jason, what's your best meal? Wait, wait, wait. We're going around the horn.
然后他就直接倒进嘴里，就像喝饮料一样。我确实是。他像喝饮料一样吃它，就像喝某种饮品。我把它塞进嘴里。杰森，你吃过最好的一顿饭是什么？等等，等等，等等。我们轮流来。
Sean, Jason, go ahead. Your favorite meal. Sean, that was it. That was your favorite meal. Spaghetti. Spaghetti is my favorite meal of all time, yeah. Okay. Do you remember a single meal, Jason, that was your best ever?
肖恩，杰森，请说。你最喜欢的一顿饭。肖恩，就是那个。那就是你最喜欢的一顿饭。意面。意面是我有生以来最喜欢的一顿饭，对。好吧。杰森，你还记得有哪一顿饭是你吃过最棒的吗？
No, but the Dodger dog and peanuts never fails at Dodger Stadium. Okay. Okay. How about that? Is that fair? Hold on. Peanuts is your favorite meal at Dodger? At a Dodger dog and peanuts never fails at Dodger Stadium. Okay. How about that? Is that fair? Hold on. Peanuts is your favorite meal at Dodger? At a Dodger dog.
不，不过道奇体育场的道奇热狗（Dodger dog）和花生永远不会出错。好吧。好吧。那个怎么样？这公平吗？等等。花生是你去道奇球场最喜欢的食物？在道奇体育场吃道奇热狗和花生永远不会出错。好吧。那个怎么样？这公平吗？等等。花生是你去道奇球场最喜欢的食物？配上一根道奇热狗。
A hot dog. This is so sad. You need me in your life, people. Jose, peanuts are full of electrolytes. They're filled with electrolytes. But my electrolytes, they know where they're coming from. Okay, sorry. I got to go to, it was memorable because i thought like i'll never
一个热狗。这太可悲了。你们的生活中需要我，各位。何塞，花生里面全是电解质。它们充满了电解质。但我的电解质，它们知道自己是从哪里来的。好吧，抱歉。我得去，这令人难忘，因为我觉得我可能永远
obviously get to do this again and i got to eat at chiro's restaurant in in tokyo oh yeah in the subway stop there do you guys ever see that i'm sure dreams of sushi and i watched him make my meal and uh and and talked with them and whatever and as much as we could understand each other and then ate this food that he made for me right there. Did it hold up? It was fantastic. And I was with a bunch of other Americans who were like, ew, this is kind of gross.
显然没机会再做一次了，我在东京的数寄屋桥次郎（Sukiyabashi Jiro）餐厅吃过饭，哦，对，就在那里的地铁站。你们看过那部电影吗？我确信是《寿司之神》（Jiro Dreams of Sushi），我看着他为我做饭，呃，然后和他们聊天，只要我们能互相理解对方，然后吃下了他就在我面前为我做的食物。它经受住考验了吗？太棒了。我和一群其他美国人在一起，他们当时反应是：呃，这有点恶心。
Like certain dishes, they're like, this is gross. They didn't want to eat it. And I was like, I'm going to eat every morsel of this because this is an experience. It's more than just the food that we're having. This is a life experience. Mine was, I changed my answer. Mine was in Vienna, Austria.
就像某些菜一样，他们会觉得：这太恶心了。他们不想吃。而我当时想：我要吃掉这里的每一小块，因为这是一次体验。这不仅仅是我们吃的食物。这是一次人生体验。我的是，我改变我的答案了。我的是在奥地利维也纳。
It was the best meal I've ever had in my entire life at some restaurant in some, I don't know, building at the top floor. It was incredible. It was a great story. Really memorable. You remember what you ate? It was meatballs and spaghetti and the place was called Mayanus too. It was very meat heavy. Jose, where do you land on microwaving?
那是我一辈子吃过最棒的一顿饭，在某个不知名建筑顶楼的一家餐厅里。太不可思议了。这是一个很棒的故事。真的令人难忘。你还记得你吃了什么吗？是肉丸配意面，那家店也叫马亚努斯（Mayanus）。肉类分量非常重。何塞，你对用微波炉加热持什么态度？
My wife gives me a lot of grief about I have to blast everything that I eat because I like to get it nice and hot so all the flavor explodes, you know, when I do happen to eat something other than a salad. That sentence. But she says that the microwave kills all the nutrients. And should I not be doing that? Do I have to put everything in a pan and heat it up slowly over a fire? Listen, if you have time, obviously cook in the fire in your kitchen and it's great. But microwave is nothing wrong for me. It's not any, it's not different
我妻子经常唠叨我，因为我把我吃的所有东西都用微波炉猛火加热，因为我喜欢把它弄得热乎乎的，这样当我的确吃除了沙拉以外的东西时，所有的风味都能完全爆发出来，你知道的。那句话。但她说微波炉会杀死所有的营养成分。我是不是不该这样做？我是不是必须把所有东西都放进平底锅里，在火上慢慢加热？听着，如果你有时间，当然可以在厨房的明火上烹饪，这很好。但微波炉对我来说没什么不好的。它没有什么不同
than anything else. Electric cooking or induction is okay, people. Actually, I have a recipe with eggs. You're going to love this one, Jason. You get one egg and one very big spoon of mayo, and you whisk them together. Oh, yeah. That's delicious. Okay, and you put it in this kind of Pyrex glass bowl, and you put it in the microwave one minute, one minute and a half. What's happening there that when you put the mayo with the eggs it's like a love affair right because the mayo is like shit what's
比其他任何东西都不同。用电烹饪或电磁炉加热是可以的，各位。其实，我有一个关于鸡蛋的食谱。你会喜欢这个的，杰森。你拿一个鸡蛋和一大勺蛋黄酱，然后把它们搅拌在一起。哦，对。太美味了。好吧，你把它放进这种派力克斯耐热玻璃碗里，然后放进微波炉转一分钟、一分钟半。这里发生的事情是，当你把蛋黄酱和鸡蛋放在一起时，就像是一场恋爱对吧，因为蛋黄酱就像是：靠，这
happening here oh shit the eggs and the eggs is like what's happening here shit the mayo it's the same shit but they're in love with each other it's like they're looking themselves at the mirror and and all the air that the mayo brings into the mix of mayo and egg makes you the best, fluffiest, kind of, I will not call it omelet, but kind of egg thing that you can make in a minute. It's just unbelievable. Unbelievable is bigger than unbelievable for you to understand.
里发生了什么，噢靠，鸡蛋；而鸡蛋就像是：靠，这里发生了什么，噢靠，蛋黄酱。它们是同一种狗屎，但它们彼此相爱。就像它们在照镜子一样，蛋黄酱带进蛋黄酱和鸡蛋混合物中的所有空气，让你做出了你在一分钟内能做出的最好、最蓬松的、我不会叫它煎蛋卷，但算是某种鸡蛋料理的东西。这简直难以置信。对于你来说，“难以置信”这个词还不足以形容它的惊人。
You know, there's a commercial made years ago by Errol Morris. They made them for Miller High Life. And it was just a picture of an empty mayonnaise jar. And the voice of this great voiceover guy called Doug Jeffers who was just an iconic guy. And he goes, we had to bail
你知道，多年前埃罗·莫里斯（Errol Morris）拍过一个广告。是为米勒清淡啤酒（Miller High Life）拍的。画面上只有一个空蛋黄酱罐子的照片。画外音是一个嗓音浑厚伟大的配音员道格·杰弗斯（Doug Jeffers），他是一个极具标志性的人物。他说，我们不得不帮
them out of two big ones. But we got to hand it to them on the mayo. Nice going, Pierre. That was it. Brilliant. We had to bail him out of two big ones is how the commercial started. Did the French invent mayonnaise, Jose?
他们摆脱了两个大麻烦。但我们在蛋黄酱这件事上不得不佩服他们。干得好，皮埃尔。就是这样。太绝了。我们不得不帮他们摆脱两个大麻烦，广告就是这样开场的。法国人发明了蛋黄酱吗，何塞？
Yeah. No. It was the people of Spain. Is that a Spanish word, mayonnaise? Totally. I have the proof. I was there. Wait, you were there when they made mayonnaise?
对。不是。是西班牙人发明的。这是一个西班牙语词汇吗，蛋黄酱（mayonnaise）？完全是。我有证据。我当时就在现场。等等，做蛋黄酱的时候你在现场？
No, you weren't. Yeah. I mean, I had more than one life. This is my fourth or fifth time. Oh, that chocolate's kicking in. Here comes the chocolate again. I mean, in other systems. I mean, the solar system is the last one I decided to join
不，我不在。对。我是说，我不止活了一辈子。这是我的第四次或第五次。哦，巧克力开始起作用了。巧克力又上头了。我是说，在其他系统中。我是说，太阳系是我最后决定加入的
because it's fun and my body can only be 60, 70, 80 years. So I keep coming back. So it's fine. So this Ma'on, you have to go back to the Balearic Islands and Menorca and Mahon. And the story is documented. And it's obviously Spanish, like everything else very much. And more important, alioli. For the people that think alioli is mayo with garlic, they're wrong.
因为这很有趣，而且我的身体只能活60、70、80年。所以我不断地回来。所以没关系。所以这个“马翁（Ma'on）”，你得追溯到巴利阿里群岛（Balearic Islands）、梅诺卡岛（Menorca）和马翁（Mahon）。这个故事是有据可查的。而且它显然是西班牙的，就像其他很多东西一样。更重要的是，蒜泥蛋黄酱（alioli）。对于那些认为蒜泥蛋黄酱就是加了蒜的蛋黄酱的人来说，他们错了。
What is it? In Catalonia, in Barcelona, alioli is made only with garlic, they're wrong. What is it? In Catalonia, in Barcelona, alioli is made only with garlic that you smash in a mortar with the help of the pestle. And then you start putting drop by drop of the oil. And you keep doing this kind of circular motion. And slowly the garlic and the oil began creating an emulsion,
那是什么？在加泰罗尼亚，在巴塞罗那，蒜泥蛋黄酱只用大蒜制作，他们错了。那是什么？在加泰罗尼亚，在巴塞罗那，蒜泥蛋黄酱只用大蒜制作，你用研钵和研杵把它们捣碎。然后你开始一滴一滴地加入油。你不断地做这种圆周运动。慢慢地，大蒜和油开始产生乳化作用，
which the emulsion is nothing more than the molecules of both ingredients began attaching to each other, began embracing each other, began like saying, I love you and I will never separate away from you. And you make a very big bowl where only has one garlic clove, where the rest is only oil, and still what you have in your hand is solid. This is mind-blowing. It's one of the most amazing traditional techniques
而乳化作用不过是这两种成分的分子开始相互依附，开始彼此拥抱，开始像是在说：我爱你，我永远不会和你分开。你做一个非常大的碗，里面只有一个大蒜瓣，其余的全部都是油，而你手里拿着的依然是固体。这太震撼了。这是最惊人的传统技艺之一，
that nobody is aware of. And therefore, Alioli and mayo, with all due respect to everybody else, they are from the country I was born. And speaking of traditional cooking, where do you land on this wave of molecular cooking where things are, they look different and they're smaller and they get frozen, freeze-dried? Yeah, I mean, listen, we talked about it before. I mentioned you, Ferran Adria. He's the father of molecular cooking, but we don't like that name.
但没有人意识到这一点。因此，蒜泥蛋黄酱和蛋黄酱，对其他人恕不恭敬，它们都来自我出生的那个国家。说到传统烹饪，你对这股分子料理的浪潮持什么态度？各种东西看起来不同，分量更小，而且被冷冻、冻干？对，我是说，听着，我们之前谈过。我提到过你，费兰·阿德里亚。他是分子料理之父，但我们不喜欢那个名字。
That name is very naughty, very stupid, actually. Let me think. Let me tell you why. Everything is molecular, people. Everything is molecular. Bread, yeast is molecular. Beer is molecular. Winemaking is molecular.
那个名字非常淘气，实际上非常愚蠢。让我想想。让我告诉你为什么。万物皆分子，各位。万物皆分子。面包，酵母是分子。啤酒是分子。酿酒是分子。
Molecules and science, they've been there forever. Sure. Now, what happens is this. Before, we had no clue what was happening in cooking. Now, we have all the answers of what's happening in the cooking. In the process, we cook better. Yeah. At the end, it's only two types of cooking.
分子和科学，它们从远古时期就一直存在。当然。现在，情况是这样的。以前，我们对烹饪中发生的事情一无所知。现在，我们掌握了烹饪中发生的一切的答案。在这个过程中，我们做饭变得更好了。是的。归根结底，烹饪其实只有两种。
Only two types, Jason. The bad cooking and the good cooking. You know, come on. It's people like chopped chicken on top of green salad and spinach. I mean, it's okay. I'm not going to use this against you. I need better options. I need to move in with you for a few
只有两种，杰森。糟糕的烹饪和美好的烹饪。你知道的，拜托。就像绿色沙拉和菠菜上面放着切碎的鸡肉。我是说，还行吧。我不会拿这个来跟你计较。我需要更好的选择。我想搬去跟你住上几个
weeks, I think. I don't think I can fix you in a few weeks. I need you like a few seasons. I need you like a few seasons. I need you like a few seasons. Yeah, like Orsak. It's like I need you a few seasons with me. My dream is for you to come over and make me spaghetti sometime.
星期，我觉得。我觉得我几周内可修不好你。我需要你像需要好几季节目那样。我需要你像需要好几季节目那样。我需要你像需要好几季节目那样。对，就像奥萨克（Orsak）。就像我需要你陪我好几季一样。我的梦想是你能过来给我做一次意大利面。
Oh, my God. If I make you, I have a book called Vegetables Unleashed. And the tomato recipe I have, the tomato sauce recipe I have for the pasta, with permission of Marcella Hassan, is the best tomato recipe I have for the pasta, with permission of Marcela Hassan, is the best tomato recipe in the history of mankind for pasta. Oh, wow. It's just astonishing. It's so simple. It's so good.
噢，天哪。如果我给你做，我有一本书叫《蔬菜大解放》（Vegetables Unleashed）。我有的那个西红柿食谱，我为意大利面做的西红柿酱食谱，在得到马塞拉·哈桑（Marcella Hassan）的许可后，那是我做意大利面用过的有史以来最好的西红柿食谱，在得到马塞拉·哈桑的许可后，那是我做意大利面用过的有史以来最好的西红柿食谱，是人类历史上做意大利面最好的西红柿食谱。噢，哇。简直太惊艳了。太简单了。太棒了。
Now you're beefing with the people of Italy. I mean, you attacked Italy. Now you're in France. I mean, this is... No, no, but hold on a second. Hold on a second. I have proof. I have proof.
现在你在和意大利人民叫板了。我的意思是，你攻击了意大利。现在你在法国。我的意思是，这... 不，不，等一下。等一下。我有证据。我有证据。
Listen, the first time ever, the first time ever, with permission of the Mexicans, the first time ever that something like, look like tomato sauce as we understand it today, it show up in an Italian book. And you know what was the name of that sauce where 90% of the ingredients were tomato? You know?
听着，破天荒头一次，破天荒头一次，在墨西哥人的允许下，破天荒头一次有类似——看起来像我们今天所理解的西红柿酱的东西，出现在了一本意大利书中。你知道那个90%的成分都是西红柿的酱汁叫什么名字吗？你知道吗？
The name of the sauce was a Spanish sauce. It's real. I have it. I have it on the books. It's history. I know it. I can prove it. I rest my case. I've never been to Spain and I'm not proud of that at all. I'm dying to go to Spain. If I were to go to Spain, do I go to Barcelona? If I want to eat the best food, do I go to Barcelona or do I go to Madrid or some other place in Spain? You have to go both. Obviously, I grew up in Barcelona. I'm a Barcelona boy. And Barcelona has amazing places.
那个酱汁的名字叫西班牙酱。这是真的。我有。我有书为证。这是历史。我知道。我能证明。我无话可说了。我从来没去过西班牙，我对此一点也不引以为豪。我做梦都想去西班牙。如果我要去西班牙，我是去巴塞罗那吗？如果我想吃最好的食物，我是去巴塞罗那还是去马德里或西班牙的其他地方？你两个都得去。很明显，我在巴塞罗那长大。我是个巴塞罗那男孩。巴塞罗那有很棒的地方。
But Madrid is. And you mentioned jamón. Oh, yeah. Will mentions jamón. That's jamón ibérico, which is this black pig that eats acorns in the last four months of their life. I remember bringing jamón ibérico to America first time 12 years ago. And what I'm very proud is that there was a series on NBC called Hannibal, which was very much the prequel of The Silence of the Lambs.
但马德里是……你提到了火腿（jamón）。哦，对。威尔提到了火腿。那是伊比利亚火腿（jamón ibérico），也就是那种在生命最后四个月吃橡果的黑猪。我记得12年前第一次把伊比利亚火腿带到美国。我很自豪的是，NBC有一部叫《汉尼拔》（Hannibal）的剧，它非常像是《沉默的羔羊》（The Silence of the Lambs）的前传。
And I became from Brian Fuller, the executive director, I became the culinary producer. And I was able to be helping the scriptwriters about stories. Oh, that's cool. And I'm very happy that in one of the episodes, I was able to get them to put an Iberico ham during two minutes as Hannibal himself was explaining how that ham was being made. And this is the moment that I said, yes.
我从执行制片人布莱恩·福勒（Brian Fuller）那里，成了美食制作人。我能够协助编剧构思故事。哦，这太酷了。我非常高兴在其中一集里，我让他们把伊比利亚火腿放了整整两分钟，当时汉尼拔本人正在解释这种火腿是如何制作的。这就是我当时说“太棒了”的时刻。
You made it. You know what? That was another good meal that I had that I'm very memorable. And I say jamon because it's so big. And I was in Madrid. And my friend who lives there full time, Andrew Newton, what's up, Newts? He was there. And we went to an Atletico game on a sunday night and then and then went for
你成功了。你知道吗？那是我吃过的另一顿非常难忘的美食。我提到火腿是因为它太棒了。我在马德里。我常驻那里的朋友安德鲁·牛顿（Andrew Newton），纽茨（Newts）最近怎么样？他在那儿。我们在一个周日晚上去看了马竞（Atletico）的比赛，然后然后去
dinner you know you go for dinner sunday night you go for dinner at like 11 30 or whatever it is after the game and that's everybody's just coming and everybody's just come with the families and little kids and everybody's sitting down to eat and i had to leave the night i had to leave at like 1 30 because i had an early flight. And everybody's, the restaurant is still packed. And little kids and families, 12, 15 people. Incredible meal. That's the Spanish way, my man. You are all welcome. You are all welcome to come and spend with me.
吃晚饭。你知道你周日晚上去吃晚饭，你在11点半左右去吃晚饭，不管比赛结束后是几点，每个人都刚来，每个人都带着家人和小孩子一起来，每个人都坐下来吃饭。我不得不离开那天晚上，我大约1点半不得不走，因为我有个早班航班。而每个人，餐馆里依然人山人海。还有小孩子和家庭，12、15个人。不可思议的一餐。这就是西班牙的方式，老兄。欢迎你们所有人。欢迎你们所有人来找我度过时光。
But Sean and Will, I'm very worried because every time I look and Jason is silent, he's having more electrolytes into his body. I am very worried that whatever he's doing after this podcast is going to be electrolyte heavy and I don't know if this is legal. I don't know
但是肖恩和威尔，我很担心，因为每次我看过去，杰森都一言不发，他正在往体内补充更多电解质。我很担心他在这个播客之后无论做什么都会摄入大量电解质，我不知道这是否合法。我不知道
if that's legal anymore. No, he's just malnourished. He eats like an entertainment executive. Like all the executives and agents in Hollywood, they all want to be thinner and in better shape
这合不合法了。不，他只是营养不良。他的饮食就像一个娱乐高管。就像好莱坞所有的执行制片人和经纪人都想比
than all the talent and I'm like, why are you in shape? Nobody cares what you look like I think they listen to your podcast so careful what you say about that
所有有天赋的人更苗条、身材更好，而我在想，你为什么要保持身材？没人关心你长什么样我想他们听了你的播客，所以小心你对这个的评价
that's okay okay if you don't want Will for any series guys I'm here I'm moving to Madrid with you Jose we're gonna eat well
没关系，好吧，如果你们谁都不想要威尔出演剧集，伙计们，我在这。我要跟你一起搬去马德里，何塞（Jose），我们要吃得很好
and we're gonna have the last laugh let's do one thing I invite you next year next summer tell me when you're free and I take the three of you to an eating spree. I would love that.
我们要笑到最后。我们做一件事，我邀请你们明年，明年夏天，告诉我你们什么时候有空，我带你们三个人去饕餮大吃一番。我太乐意了。
Give me five days and your life will change forever. I would love that. In Spain? In Spain? Yeah. I am Jose Andres and I do endorse this message. Oh, wow. I've never been.
给我五天时间，你的人生将发生翻天覆地的变化。我太乐意了。在西班牙？在西班牙？对。我是何塞·安德烈斯（Jose Andres），我支持这条信息。哦，哇。我从来没去过。
I've never been, so I want to go. Well, guess what? On our European tour, we're going to hit Barcelona. On our SmartList European tour, which we're going to do after our North American tour, we're going to come to Madrid or Barcelona. You pick. We'll go to whatever city you're in. What works for you, Jose?
我从来没去过，所以我想去。好吧，你猜怎么着？在我们的欧洲巡演中，我们要去巴塞罗那。在我们的SmartLess欧洲巡演中，也就是我们在北美巡演之后要做的巡演，我们要去马德里或巴塞罗那。你来挑。你去哪个城市，我们就去哪个。对你来说哪个合适，何塞？
And we're going to have you on stage for SmartList, and then we're going to go and we're going to do the culinary thing. We're going to do all of it. We're going to shoot all of it, and we're going to keep all the money. But here's the thing. We should have gummies before all of it. We're going to shoot all of it. And we're going to keep all the money. But here's the thing. We should have gummies before and then we do it. Don't you worry about it. Defo.
我们要邀请你上台录制SmartLess，然后我们要去享受美食。我们要把所有的都体验一遍。我们要把这一切都拍下来，而且我们要把所有的钱都留下。但关键是，我们在这一切开始之前应该先吃点软糖。我们要把这一切都拍下来。我们要把所有的钱都留下。但关键是，我们在开始之前应该先吃点软糖，然后我们再录。你们不用担心。绝对的。
Defo. Oh, defo. Jose, you've been very, very nice with your time today, sir. Thank you so much. Thank you, Jose. It's such a pleasure meeting you. What a delight. What an incredible person you are.
绝对的。哦，绝对的。何塞，今天你花了很多很多时间，非常感谢你，先生。非常感谢你。谢谢你，何塞。很高兴认识你。太荣幸了。你是一个多么不可思议的人啊。
It's amazing. Such a thrill to meet you. I'm amazed that people like you can have a podcast, guys. And I feel, you know, really, I feel you love being part of it. I still, what I know about America is it's an amazing country. And if three people like you can have a successful podcast like this, anything is possible in America. Anybody can.
太棒了。能见到你真是太激动了。我真惊讶像你们这样的人居然能拥有一个播客，伙计们。我觉得，你知道，真的，我觉得你们很享受其中。对于美国，我依然了解的是，这是一个伟大的国家。如果像你们三个人这样的人能拥有这样一个成功的播客，在美国一切皆有可能。任何人都可以。
And thank you for giving me that opportunity to belong. Immigrants like me, thank you. We thank you. Same as a Canadian, same. Okay, thank you, Jose. Thank you, sir. Please enjoy. Go tend to your stew, the octopus stew. I would love to show you.
谢谢你给我这种归属感。像我这样的移民，谢谢你。我们谢谢你。和一个加拿大人一样，一样。好的，谢谢你，何塞。谢谢你，先生。请慢用。去照顾你的炖菜吧，那个章鱼炖菜。我很乐意带你们看看。
The octopus is amazing, I'll tell you. Bye, guys. All right, thank you. Have a great day. Bye, buddy. See ya. Wow. So now when I said at the beginning that he's going to be cutting some lines up in heaven
章鱼太棒了，我跟你说。再见，伙计们。好的，谢谢。祝你们有美好的一天。再见，老兄。回头见。哇。所以现在当我在开头说他将来上了天堂
whenever he goes, it's true, right? I mean— You don't mean chopping up lines like in the bathroom? No, no, no, no, no. Cutting lines. Like, they're not going to let make him wait going through the gates up there, right? You know what's interesting, though? Those really famous chefs that are so talented, they're all so gregarious.
会去切几道线（吸毒/排队双关）的时候，这是真的，对吧？我是说——你不是指像在卫生间里切那种线吧？不，不，不，不，不。切线。我是说，他们不会让他排队等候通过那上面的大门，对吧？你知道有趣的是什么吗？那些真正才华横溢的超级名厨，他们都那么热情外向。
They're all so outgoing, aren't they? There's no like introverted chef. I don't think you can be. No. But they are famously nasty at times, right?
他们都那么外向，对吧？没有哪个厨师是内向的。我觉得你不可能内向。没错。但他们有时也出了名的刻薄，对吧？
They can be pushed. They can be. He doesn't seem nasty. But I love that it took him a while and he warmed up and he really got the flavor of what we're doing here, which is nothing
他们会被逼急的。确实会。他看起来不刻薄。但我喜欢他花了一点时间才热络起来，而且他真的抓住了我们在这里做的精髓，那就是无所事事
and just screwing around. Right. And then he just started screwing around and he ends it with just basically clowning us, saying that if you guys can have a podcast, anybody can. And I love that. Yeah, he sniffed it out.
只是在瞎胡闹。没错。然后他开始瞎胡闹，最后以基本上在开我们的玩笑结束，说如果你们这帮家伙能做播客，那任何人都可以。我太喜欢这样了。对，他闻出味儿来了。
I love anybody like that. I love, I've got all the time in the world for that. Jason, what a great idea. I've often, and we brought it up before to him, it seems like in the last few years. Just about the restaurant? No, just that he shows up all the time. Every time that there's something going on
我喜欢任何这样的人。我愿意为此付出所有的时间。杰森，真是个好主意。我经常——我们之前也向他提过，似乎在过去的几年里。就为了那家餐厅？不，只是他总是出现。每当有事情发生
that's really major in the world where people are hungry and he's there. And God, it's such a great example of, it's not dissimilar. I mean, we all do it in our own way. Sean, I know that you went down to the thing and Jason, I've seen you give out selfies at the Grove before, but like, you know, we-
世界各地发生大事，人们挨饿的时候，他就在那里。天哪，这真是一个极好的榜样，这并不罕见。我的意思是，我们都在用自己的方式这样做。肖恩，我知道你去过那个地方，杰森，我以前见过你在格罗夫（Grove）发自拍，但是，你知道，我们——
Whatever it takes. But you know what? Every single thing that Jose, every piece of food that Jose was talking about made me want to take a bite. How long have you been sitting on that? How long? I wrote it down halfway through.
不惜一切代价。但你知道吗？何塞说的每一件事，何塞谈到的每一口食物都让我想咬上一口。你这话憋了多久了？多久了？我写下来写到一半的时候。
You did? Oh, God, that's so... Now, what did he say about planning? What happens when you overly plan? Nothing happens well. And like, because we haven't said goodbye, so my thing didn't work. Right. And we didn't even end it.
真的吗？哦，天哪，太……现在，他是怎么说计划的？过度计划会发生什么？什么都不会顺利。而且，因为我们还没说再见，所以我的那个梗没起作用。没错。而且我们甚至都没结束节目。
We haven't ended it. That's what I mean. It didn't even work. Oh, my God. Dude, that bite. Used the same word, but a different bite. That works. That's a win.
我们还没结束呢。这就是我的意思。甚至都没起作用。哦，天哪。老兄，那一口。用了同一个词，但咬了不同的一口。这行得通。这是一场胜利。
Smart. Worse. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wondery.com survey today hip-hop dominates pop culture but
聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。如果你喜欢《SmartLess》，现在就可以通过加入Wondery App或Apple Podcasts上的Wondery Plus提前收听无广告版。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上无广告收听。在你离开之前，请在今天访问wondery.com/survey填写简短问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。嘻哈音乐主导了流行文化，但是
it wasn't always like that and to tell the story of how that changed i want to take you back to a very special year in rap 88 it was too much good music. The world was on fire. I'm Will Smith. This is Class of 88, my new podcast about the moments, albums, and artists that inspired a sonic revolution and secured 1988 as one of hip-hop's most important years. We'll talk to the people who were there. And most of all, we'll bring you some amazing stories.
情况并非一直如此。为了讲述这一切是如何改变的，我想带你们回到说唱界一个非常特殊的年份——88年。当时有太多好听的音乐了。世界都在沸腾。我是威尔·史密斯。这是《88届》（Class of 88），我的新播客，讲述了激发一场声音革命并确保1988年成为嘻哈音乐最重要的年份之一的那些时刻、专辑和艺术家。我们将与亲历者对话。最重要的是，我们会带给你们一些精彩绝伦的故事。
You know what my biggest memory from that tour is? It was your birthday. Yes, and you brought me to Shoday. Life-size cardboard cutout. This is Class of 88, the story of a year that changed hip-hop. Follow Class of 88 on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道我对那次巡演最大的记忆是什么吗？是你的生日。没错，你把我带到了肖代（Shoday）。等身纸板立牌。这是《88届》，一个改变了嘻哈音乐的历史年份的故事。在Wondery App或你获取播客的任何地方关注《88届》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。